on envoie le petit red
on envoie le petit raid et on va se
mettre l'échiquier qui a pas encore
apparu
tu n'es pas encore apparu puisque la
partie n'a pas encore commencé
ça y est il est là donc le 4 d444 sans
nous on était plus ou moins sûr
ça part sur 4 c'est plus le premier coup
des Noirs qui sera en question faxer
Maurice Ashley non derrière
il y a un genre de contre-jour avec
porte-revue sont tout cas c'est sûr mais
moi je sais qu'il fait les résumés pour
la NBC
conférence de presse oui
on dit oui c'est Maurice alors en fait
quelques où il va il va faire jouer à
l'invité elle va réussir à jouer surtout
ça la question
et chaque fois il faut un coup différent
de l'inviter à tu me change tout de
suite
83 en fait je peux pas ne pas mettre bas
qui 83 à
10h c'était une idée de dis ça on est
sûr comme donc forcément Baki 83 c'était
une idée de 10 moules pour les
prochaines cette bataille de mettre au
premier ticket Baki 83 à autre chose et
Messi qui est pas qui 83p
ça pourrait changer beaucoup de choses
Baki des fois ça commence en avance des
fois ça commence en retard mais j'arrive
jamais à savoir jusqu'à maintenant il
commençait plutôt vers 13h28 j'étais
toujours sur
C4 encore c'est ça
il fait jouer ces quatre mais
c'est 400 coups qui peut jouer mais bon
mais moi ça y est c'est parti en tout
cas Étienne il réfléchit
pas trop
il est
dans un match de
mais envoie le cavalier C6 bah il rejoue
marche alors
pas de surprise il va il va tenter une
petite poussette peut-être mon fou des
deux celui de Maxime Caruana
est pas bien
mais bon il a quand même des petites
poussettes si c'est la troisième
c'est vraiment très bizarre
c'est si c'est tout
même toi qui reste bien concentré dans
son match je suis assez étonné que là ça
fait deux parties quasiment son jouet et
c'est pas trop dans dans son style
Ouais mais ça veut dire aussi peut-être
qui craint Iliana
il respecte beaucoup son adversaire
mais bon c'est quand même un meilleur
c'est quand même un meilleur joueur donc
en globalité oui oui mais en plus tu
t'approches du coup du prix d'un coup
plus ça peut tourner d'un côté ou de
l'autre et on rapide il aura pas si ce
sera pas si simple de de Bastia nom des
partages
favoris
qui va partir une nouvelle fois
en grande surprise ou B Quattro
est-ce qui chante ça c'est un peu lequel
change en premier en tout cas il y a une
il veut lui dire j'ai une idée dans ta
tête tu vas pas faire les deux c'est ce
qui va répéter ton foutez de moi il y a
pas mal de cou impossible c'est
dans cavalier BD2 ça semblait ah c'est
fermé quand même j'ai pas ben j'ai pas
regardé
énormément mais un petit peu quand même
peut-être que ma nièce n'a pas révisé il
s'attendait pas répéter encore
il veut pas voir le Marchal
la 4 c'est un bon copain Maxime il a
gagné contre
Ding liren première partie des candidats
avec son coup et là c'est vraiment
devenu le coup je tombe de sommeil tu as
ouais ok on va voir une game c'est bien
tombé 8 ça m'a pas l'air terrible
Mariama de Bisschop la qui commence
à se frotter les mains
8 allée vu dans on avait vu dans la base
un qui avait du tour B8 avec
Maxime il l'a vu non car il a joué
dehors bébé je crois ouais c'est pas là
c'était la partie du Grand Suisse non
je sais plus je regarde tellement que je
sais plus en ce moment du coup il rejoue
son H3 un meilleur moment quand même je
compare avec la première partie il a
l'air content en plus il se lève ou et
Magnus a pas l'air si content
OK
ça me l'a fait sur la chaise et ses
revenus s'asseoir dans l'air confiant là
il a l'air content la
3 si tu regardes la première partie tu
avais encore le pion à Dole pleurer si
cela tu auras vite là c'est un gros
avantage d'avoir ouvert la colonne à il
y a plus trop de fou B7 parce que le
pion B5 va être faible
donc comme ça visuellement ça a l'air
très intéressant pour pour Yann un gros
plan
Syriane peut-être
il a l'air confiant
et tu vois Magnus peut-être qu'il avait
pas envie de rejouer une partie comme
celle d'avant où il devait se souvenir
de tous les coups pour faire nul
rapidement qu'ils au secours un peu plus
petit tour B8 pour avoir plus de
possibilités mais là il peut tomber sur
sur une prépa ok je connais quand même
c'est
bien
Ouais ouais parce qu'en plus le fou avec
l'échange des pions à il a plus trop
cette case
b773 tempo c'est logique que j'ai 4 ans
pêcher il va jouer pour des 4
donc il va
c'est
pas une case ça va trop affaiblir dans
dans l'italienne y a souvent du faux
aussi mais là on sent que ça va toucher
vite il est très très content mais voilà
c'est moi je commence à suer un petit
peu
se mettre Bishop la qui se frotte les
mains
chante l'assurance n'est pas dans le
chat de partout les gestes les coups
jouer avec une réflexion inférieure qui
vient de loin une partie de bonhomme
aujourd'hui
en tout cas ça se peut qu'il aime les
mêmes près sont-ils tourbé 8 et qu'il
est ce matin
c'est il est pas VIP c'est c'est Maxime
on
est plus
on a plus on a on a rien du tout en fait
on a pas de VIP on a pas de truc ok
ouais non mais ok il a raison on retombe
dans 1
dans une espagnol améliorer on était
déjà dans une dans la première partie
améliorer la D6 C3
c'est quoi le seul avantage noir c'est
quoi ces 2
je sais pas
d'avoir d'avoir peut-être Dubé Quattro
quelque part mais
d'ailleurs mais bon pas trop
mais voilà enfin c'est peut-être le seul
avantage tu vois d'avoir d'avoir
toujours et jamais dans l'opposition ici
peut-être que tu peux
réfléchir de toute façon j'ai envie de
te dire fondamentalement
c'est que cette position elle doit être
plus ou moins correct quand même et ça
veut dire que l'ordi si tu le pousse à
fond il va finalement donné 0 0 0 mais
c'est pas sûr
ça peut être il a pu il a pu être étonné
qui répète ce dire de toute façon il
répétera pas parce que j'étais trop fort
la partie d'avant et puis là peut-être
qu'il a pas révisé ce matin il s'est dit
la sur l'échiquier il va me dire si
jamais ce qui se passe pourquoi du coup
c'est la 5e partie
de la 5e partie des fois tes failles a
des jours où tu es fatigué ou tu révises
moins tu prends des et le fait qu'ils
aient beaucoup de nul là ça peut ça peut
perturber les devoirs tout ça tout ça je
l'entends Baki mais dans ces cas-là
pourquoi cliquet 3/8 aussi rapidement
c'est plus à ma question en fait
parce que tu mets un peu de pression tu
dis bah tu
pars en fait tu cliques rapidement pour
dire oui j'avais préparé 8 je suis bien
au courant de tout ce qui se passe
s'il était au courant
s'il était vraiment au courant et qu'il
était hyper bien préparé il aurait déjà
Magnus pas très bien il n'est peau hyper
Fringants c'est vrai que
et oui il a raison avec toi quand même
connaître encore
on peut être étonné de toute façon donc
on sait pas on sait pas
il a pas il s'est pas levé
ma place à quelqu'un je pense que non
non tu pensais que ça allait à peine ça
aussi ça va cliquer ok
mais là ça a l'air très bien préparer
côté mais pour ça
il a pas eu des parties comme ça
on va lui demander
se rappelle-t-il il en joue beaucoup
aussi Maxime des game
on peut plus être des 3 non c'est très
pas
chaque profondeur 47 ils sont 1 + 0 0 9
j'ai envie de te dire c'est déjà ça
prend 1 + 0 0 9
ouais
ok il va jouer bcbc de toute façon pour
ouvrir la colonne et retirer
peut-être qu'il peut essayer de
retourner dans un truc comme Lemarchal
faire un baisser BCD cinko
pour aller vite pour les Noirs parce que
si
si tu joues tranquillement tu vas être
moins bien
voir quelque chose comme ça
tu vois la photo là ça peut être
à mon avis il faut tenter dans
donc ça là il peut y avoir des trucs de
prépa mais en fait si tu vas pas très
vite
avec les Noirs tu vas tu vas être moins
bien il est joue des 3 pourquoi parce
que sur des 4 c'était probablement puis
on prend ses 3 pieds en français 3 puis
on prend des quatre puis on prend et des
cinq
ça ressemble tu vois ça peut ça peut
être ça
de toute façon si il a fait des trois
avec beaucoup d'assurance pour le moment
c'est sûr à 202000 pourcents même qui
connaît Yann
et Manu ça a l'air de connaître en mode
inquiet en mode ouais ce qu'il y a
après un peu comme la partie dit hier
par exemple ou
si il a pas tout ça devient un peu
embêtant sur l'échiquier c'est vrai que
je regardais tu vois j'étais au sport je
te regarde et puis on voit que mais
quand même tu vois sur l'échiquier tu te
dis
après au commentaire ça se voyait
tellement que on était confiant que tu
dis on sait on sait qu'il a Messi il a
pas tu vois quand tu réfléchis 100 ans
il a pas il était pas bien
comme comme ce genre de position là il
faut que Magnus mon avis il doit
connaître jusqu'au bout sinon il va
vraiment en danger
mais c'est là que les les échecs voilà
tu as un côté psychologique et un côté
bleu qui est vraiment important qui
existe pas au niveau en ferrailleur
enfin trouvé les couilles ici c'est pas
facile parce que tu as combien de coups
toi tu en as beaucoup ça peut être aussi
ça peut être remis et ça peut être fou
aussi ça peut être fou 17 ça peut être
des 5 tu as trop de en vrai même pour
être pour être un coup en français 3 je
pense qu'il va le faire
parce que puis on prend il a fait en le
voir ça c'est obligatoire prendre du
cavalier ça peut être une idée j'imagine
que non il a pris du pain en même pour
te poser une question pour te faire une
passe
c'est possible d'y réfléchir mais ça
c'est pas logique
là il est en train de réfléchir dessine
quoi ou pas en fait il va se concentrer
beaucoup sur Décines koala
il boit un petit peu
bon mais ça se peut qu'il est encore
mais juste qu'il essaie de
d'anticiper ce qui peut arriver est la
chanson qui là c'est quelqu'un qui
essaie de se rappeler là quand tu
regardes comme ça dans le vide ou
j'essaie de voir à quel endroit il peut
avoir un problème on sait jamais ou
peut-être qu' il est moins sur sur sur
ça je sais pas
pense à quelque chose plus loin quoi
papa sur la position qu'il a
actuellement il pense à quelque chose
d'autre part il a peut-être des options
il a moi mon avis c'est plutôt des cinq
enfin soit ça marche soit un peu moins
bien
peut-être que il y a une longue ligne
qu'il a pas envie de s'en souvenir et du
coup qui va jouer un coup à côté on sait
jamais quoi
pas vraiment
c'est vraiment difficile à ce niveau-là
ce ce côté après pas même même à
appréhender pour les les spectateurs
j'imagine tu vois qu'ils ont jamais joué
de tournoi au même qui qui joue un peu
le weekend mais là c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui t'a pas toi c'est pas
toi même déjà préparé il t'a pas jouer à
plus ou moins au niveau c'est très
difficile de te projeter dans la
réflexion que que Magnus pas avoir la
comme ça je viens de réfléchir peut-être
que il y a aussi du H6
cavalier bd25
jeux des cavaliers prends pour qui est
le pion ans et 3 ans qui se fasse
toucher à ce moment-là il y a toujours
il y a des fois il y a des nuances on
est jamais sûr tu vois donc peut-être
c'est sûr qu'il va jouer un truc à base
de dessin qu' est-ce que c'est pas grave
si c'est ce que pasa passe d'abord par
ash68 par des 5 tout de suite
mais c'est c'est le truc si ça joue que
sur des nuances et tu peux pas tu peux
te rappeler mais si tu te rappelles pas
tu peux plus avoir c'est pas possible
c'est trop ça te ressemble trop trop
avec des
petits ajout de cookies pas ajouter ne
pas ajouter il y a peut-être un ordre
très précis qui égaliser un autre qui
n'existe pas et ça c'est vrai que c'est
très difficile en tout cas il a pas
l'air
[Musique]
à l'aise il a pas l'air action encore
mais il a pas l'air à l'aise c'est que
c'est non
non ça va
c'est tout cassé
j'ai cassé le
siège
c'est magnifique
debout demain
mais c'est parce que c'est pas la chaîne
sais mais si c'est pour ça j'en ai en
fait et oui j'ai pas de faire les garde
et Messi qui qui regarde qui va arriver
pour le prêt avant avant la fin du
tournoi il me faudrait une petite souris
aussi
petite souris
on va équiper le prenne
ok en tout cas
passez à l'aise
il est pas à l'aise après attends est-ce
qu'on a le temps là je sais pas du tout
il a quand même ça fait pas longtemps
qu'il réfléchit mais
j'arrive jamais à les voir en fait
est-ce que tu aimes bien cette vue de
cam on voit les pièces justement
Fidea les pièces vides d'ailleurs moi je
mets les chevaux comme Magnus
mais pas comme
ils sont de côté moi j'arrive pas à les
avoir je crois qu'il mais je crois qu'il
aimait vers le centre
moi je vais aussi vers le soir alors que
mes potes à droite
il va
j'ai 3
ans
il a une petite il a été
justement
et oui tu as les coups quand même en bas
qui ont 100 ans d'expérience
tu sais pas trop il peut pas trop pas
trop attendre sinon
sinon ça va être moins bien ça serait
tellement étonnant qu'il est pas qu'il
est passé
quand même
ça a l'air d'être hyper mails non mais
bon il peut l'avoir très loin encore oui
il aurait pu gagner mais donc c'est ce
qu'on a vu tout à l'heure puis on prend
cavalier prends qui va les prendre 5
cavaliers prends tu prends
6 ou 3 sur C4
après à tout de suite ou peut-être tout
de suite je sais tout de suite de pièces
donc ici il y a quoi c'est deux
mais pareil faut F6C présent C3 ok il y
a pas de même pas vraiment un Gambie en
réalité ouais ça récupère tout donc
donc il a
et là c'est pas facile parce qu'en fait
si tu joues dès que tu as toujours ce
problème en C8
ouais tu vois si tu joues DODO tu as
toujours ce problème du Fou
et du cavalier C6 qu'est-ce que
peut-être fou des 6 avec des cavaliers
au 7 mai non après
c'est quoi les plantes faut
dire non
aussi
on va pas on va juste essayer de voir
les options donc c'est soit prise prise
food et 6 et après cavalier cavalier qui
peut repartir cet G6 voir dame 7 x 6
blanc
un tout petit peu de vent quoi dans ce
truc qui
est pas mal quand même au final
soit x 6 tout de suite mais faut aussi
non pas ici il faut aussi ce qu'on prend
des fois ça marche dans l'italien tout
ça comme il y a trop trop trop faible et
le cavalier c'est si c'est trop mauvais
là ça va pas en C-4 a minima pour
pour avoir un peu comme tout à l'heure
sur puis on prend cavalier prends ta C3
mais bon tu on peut avoir du dame C2
simplement cavalière 4 c'est compliqué
là faut faire gaffe au tour à 6
généralement dans ses positions
qui peuvent exister pour taper là et là
mais il faut aussi j'aime pas trop
j'aime pas trop et puis on prend puis on
prend est fou des 6
c'est sûr que ça que ce n'est pas qui va
avoir une chance de poussière
avec une bonne défense ça doit quand
même être pas suffisant mais est-ce
qu'on peut essayer de jouer sans 2dec
il va pas avoir trop envie
donc si c'est pas fou aussi
fou B7 j'aime pas
peut-être h66
joue
alors jusqu'à Val tu peux prendre qu'à
tes d'un problème et ça suffit
est-ce que je suis obligé de reprendre
du Fou 4h en prise il y a tout qui
empêche obligé de reprendre du Fou et là
je perds trop de temps par contre
si si il y a il y a quoi si c'est un
coup pour chaque fois tu temporise tu
laisses ton tour à 6 par contre là il y
a 2 pouces
4 soit pion prend cavalier prends et
dame qui a l'air aussi assez bien pour
les blancs en vrai
déjà parce que c'est tu touches mais il
y a peut-être juste
avec
17 x 5
non ça c'est moins bien là-bas
OK
ça tient juste et on aurait pas de bol
pour
un mais je pense pas que tu du coup tu
presse autant d'option que tu as déjà
l'option x 4 / h 6 mais pas que ça
mais après peut-être que tu peux encore
jouer du
tour acide raciste toujours non
un peu embêtant
il va falloir faire des fous des 6
mai
2006 comme on lui disait
parce qu'on a deux mauvaises pièces avec
les Noirs le cavalier C6 et le foot
et là ça permet de défendre 5 de
recycler en fait si le cavalier bouge le
fou il est il va se développer tout seul
en fait il est auto développé
une fois que tu es en G6 et en plus il
aura plus de fou B7 pour taper sur e46
ouais ça de ça sera peut-être ça et la
cavalier fin
puis cavalier cavalier le 7 10 ans
j'ai 3 ans cavalier
g666 d'abord
il a fait des erreurs
c'est possible qu'ils aient encore
en avoir mais
mais bon ça a l'air plus agréable pour
les blancs et la le prix d'un coup va
quand même être cher Ouais là ça va être
ça
un mauvais coup il pète très très mal
mais il a il a pas là il a pas l'air
bien dans le langage corporel
on dit c'est pas qui qui devra affronter
Magnus elle t'avait fait un beau match
en Coupe du monde
malheureusement la première mais il
avait beaucoup réfléchi dans la voiture
j'ai mal évalué il m'habille il a très
très
fort dans ses positions c'est moi
c'est difficile et j'ai pas senti le
moment dans la première où il fallait
vraiment jouer pour nul en fait parce
que sinon en rapide ok j'avais aussi
méchant je vais bien en rapide très très
bien même en ce moment je vais
rapidement
malheureusement
après
après ou noir tu avais fait une belle
partie mon machin et tout mais non je
vais faire un beau match mais il a un
peu plus fort que moi dans tous les
domaines sauf peut-être qu'il avait un
peu trop réfléchi et que j'ai un peu
manqué de chance de pas poser un
problème de plus en fait
mais j'ai jamais eu de position vraiment
pour gagner au pour ta sortie vraiment
une très belle partie mais ça tu as
préparé tes belles sur la 4 machin
attends il faut
un petit me rapprocher ok
il faut
qui est plus fort il n'a pas voulu
humilier de saumon norvégien
j'ai pas voulu me qualifier tout de
suite pour les candidats et je voulais
jouer les Grands Prix vide pour faire
[Musique]
entre février mais j'ai pas de compte
j'ai pas de contrat j'ai pas de j'ai pas
de
ils ont dit Berlin mais peut-être
Belgrade peut-être machin. On va être
ans et non
pas à ce point-là
ça va se faire c'est juste
après on verra quand même parce que il y
a des complexités inattendu attendu
qu'ils sont revenus
donc
je me dis
que
peut-être que tout le monde
après c'est vrai que pour les Grands
Prix fait 10 trouve que pour ce tournoi
là c'est pas comme au grand Suisse ou
s'il y a beaucoup de joueurs qui s'en
vont tu fais quand même le tournoi à la
scie sur un Grand Prix tu as 18 joueurs
sur le temps à 22h c'est pas très
équitable quoi
ouais ben je m'en fous des séismes
après je sais je sais pas si c'est les
meilleurs
c'est la meilleure coupe en tout casser
les couilles main
tomber
il a tout fait tomber Magnus il a remis
il a doublé les pièces il est parti
voilà je pense que ça par
cavaliers fin là ça devrait jouer très
rapidement encore
si tu allais coup ça sert à rien de me
le fait de réfléchir non moi c'est
tellement naturel que ça me
paraît 36 réfléchi longtemps là n'est
pas
alors on nous demande une question
combat qui joue à un tournoi ou et elle
joue lui aussi comment il se prépare
est-ce que tu s quand même Maxime c'est
une question qui revient tellement
souvent je profite que tu sois là pour
pour te la poser
bah on joue pas souvent ensemble mais
quand ça arrive bah c'est arrivé à Paris
par exemple on a joué quoi
pour la préparation de Maxime voilà
c'est du rapide du coup on
verra on a pas les dates on n'a pas
tu dois faire un truc
par exemple
il est bloqué
[Rires]
c'est quand même embêtant quand tu joue
contre quelqu'un tu prépares
Grand Prix
il y a des cas où ça peut être embêtant
mais c'est comme ça
après pour les ouvertures ça va être
particules et quand tu joues contre
Maxime
enfin c'est vrai on a on a un vrai on
n'a jamais on n'a quasiment jamais
Ouais mais genre là le grand pas grand
il m'envoie maîtresse et moi j'envoie le
crime était très heureux
vous allez pas vous envoyer des Najdorf
ou des
je sais pas encore mais non mais ce
serait pas ça serait bizarre en tout cas
je peux te dire que souvent pendant une
partie je pense
[Rires]
parce que je te l'ai montré quand j'ai
joué contre
quoi
mail à moi
c'est magnifique que tu lui dises à la
fin de la partie
elle était sympa cette partie contre
Pavidis oui pas qui grâce à la partie
que j'ai joué contre lui avec avantage
il a trouvé le 4 incroyable ah oui c'est
incroyable ça et non parce qu'en plus on
en avait parlé de cette partie contre
Vlad et je l'avais complètement oublié
mais
avant avant enfin bon il y a pas
longtemps et j'étais sûr d'avoir perdu
contre Vlad j'étais pas sûr mais je
crois que j'ai perdu et puis il y a
quelqu'un donc il nous a dit non tu
avais fait nul à
c'était aux Émirats on avait joué et je
me rappelle que tu m'avais dominer et
c'était en fait en ce moment c'est un
peu surprenant pas eu ce genre de
position tu vois il y a une dizaine
d'années c'était un peu quand tu faisais
des nul c'était un peu et c'est vrai que
j'ai fait la même chose contre
c'était énorme
si vous avez loupé cette vidéo Alicia et
elle a un truc et voilà
tout tout il y a beaucoup de tes vidéos
qui sont très instructive même même pas
au niveau c'est très bien expliqué très
c'est pour tout le monde mais non mais
ça là on a vraiment on a on a vraiment
bosser longtemps parce que je sais pas
il était passionné par l'ouverture le
cavalier 3D 5 g 3 qui trouve ça
intéressant
ok donc il réfléchit surprenant parce
que c'est
vraiment la
roue libre
pas du tout je vais jouer contre j'ai
joué à la Coupe du monde contre Iron
3 déjà j'ai vu 4 fois en fait c'est
ouverture
oui je connaissais d'avant enfin il
avait joué contre
quand j'ai préparé quand j'avais 7 ans
du coup ouais bah c'est assez
intéressant tu es assez bizarre
parce que
tu veux vraiment les coups très humain
en fait mais là c'est comme si il avait
plus peut-être que c'est pas les
meilleurs coups mais
mais c'est trop humain et là je trouve
ça un peu bizarre de réfléchir à ce
moment-là un peu dommage il parce que
même si c'est un peu mieux pour les
blancs il va perdre de la pression
réfléchissant trop je t'aime c'est de ok
ah bah il fallait il fallait
et en fait très intéressant parce que il
pense que dame ces deux c'est un coup
forcé
il réfléchit encore entre cavalier fin
et cavalier C4
mais ils estiment que c'est un coup
c'est une case obligatoire pour la dame
qui commence pour se garder un maximum
de flexibilité voilà par exemple
peut-être que sur cavalier cette il va
jouer cavalier C4 est sur H6 cavalier F1
enfin
un exemple mais juste il décide que
c'est la case en fait
elle est bien placé tu défends le pion
tu tu enlèves de la colonne tu peux
décaler sur à deux peut-être un jour
pour taper
je fais beaucoup de choses en ces deux
en réalité et évite les finales bon
c'est belle case et tu peux pas être
touché
non c'est une belle casse pour la dame
mais
après là je pense qu'il va jouer
caballos est quand même assez cavalier
c'est toi je t'ai sans doute
forcément il y a pas trop de pas trop de
choix la petite Micro turbine est elle
propose un dame 8 aussi mais j'aime pas
du tout
bizarre après si tu veux que si tu veux
que je mette cette position parce que là
il va réfléchir
à l'ordi est allumé dans cinq minutes
non mais si c'est intéressant ou pas
parce que là ça va vraiment jouer des
micros détail donc on peut on va pouvoir
savoir vas-y comment tu veux qu'on
ne bouge pas
il faut juste que tu me donnes ton
Internet
c'est bien ah bah ouais on fait comme
à la maison
regarde sur ceceba qui a l'option c'est
c'est aussi un peu faible
des 37 détrompez-vous
détrompez-vous je ne vais pas regarder
sur une machine aussi faible
et en plus
là par contre faut juste que je prenne
mon
tél la 5G ne peux pas arrêter pas qui
que non
les devoirs se sont mis d'accord pour
faire 14 nul 10 mars et que mes
paupières en rapide l'un prends des
points Hello estar la tête pas trop
Batman garde le titre ça m'étonnerait
Martigues qu'il y ait ce genre
d'arrangement
ah non ça paraît complexe imagine c'est
la chance d'une vie pour une peau c'est
l'objectif d'une vie même
c'est génial quoi de pouvoir
c'est quoi le format pour le j'étais
comment sont définis les deux qualifiés
dans chaque Grand Prix aura des points
un peu comme
[Musique]
les deux premiers classement à la fin
des des Grands Prix recevront une place
pour le tournoi des candidats
et les candidats on sait à quand quelle
date ils ont lieu mon prochain juin ou
juillet ça va être rapide en fait parce
qu'ils veulent l'an prochain en fin
d'année on aura un autre championnat du
monde qu'on a priori ils ont pris du
retard pour celui-là mais qui sera
rattrapé la fin juin début juillet quoi
je peux pas te dire
non mais j'adorais pour le match France
- Russie
dès que les compositions a été donné le
match était clair il a très bien su que
Maxime allez allez gagner
mais il a très bien expliqué en fait ça
s'est passé exactement le schéma quand
on cherchait
les d'été déjà je t'ai enfin sur cette
partie
mets
appeler commentaire toujours très très
très intéressant de Vlad ça me fait
penser tu sais à l'oracle dans Matrix
qui dit vous n'êtes pas là pour pour
faire des choix où tout est tracé vous
êtes là pour comprendre pourquoi vous
avez fait ses choix ça c'est comme lad
du n'est pas là pour savoir qui a gagné
le match ça c'est déjà fait quand et
qu'on pourrait te donner c'est
comprendre pourquoi ils ont gagné c'est
magnifique
ok donc tour B8
ça va été déjà jouer à Doodle ah bah oui
d'accord Coupe du monde donc juste après
Magnus m'avait jouer A4 B7 comme il a
joué la troisième ronde et 2 jours après
contre Douda il avait joué sur la A4 B8
et d'être dans 4 ans B5
mars 2023 match il me semble ok
concert que le prochain match il sera
dans 15 mois ils vont essayer moi je
pense qu'ils vont essayer de le faire
avant H3 était déjà joué par là il y a
longtemps il y a quoi 2005 ok on ça n'a
pas beaucoup d'importance
H3
D673 des 4 des 3 bah ils ont joué ça a
été joué en 2005 déjà
ok
de votre des Français
305 on en est où la cavalier
prise prise un fou des 6
ça fait pas partie des premier coup de
l'ordi
c'est pour ça qu'il s'est mis à
réfléchir et c'était H6 ok très très
bizarre bizarre avec le corps donc
c'était dans cette position ok ok pas
très grosse profondeur mais quand même
ça fait mesdames ces deux non plus
dommage
c'est x 4 ouais non c'est compliqué là
là ça réfléchit
mesdames ces deux
on va laisser ça non
non non non
on va pas on va savoir assez rapidement
en fait on va savoir assez rapidement
voilà vite fait donne H6 quand même mais
bon
il va me combien il est entre 0 30
on va voir on va voir il faut attendre
un peu est-ce que c'est pas un type de
positions que Manu joue mieux quand même
ses positions un peu alors sur les sur
les détails alors là le
le truc c'est que par rapport à la
position que j'ai eu contre Magnus tu as
plus de structure de pion
tu as plus d'activité vraiment possible
pour la se joue vraiment pour nul avec
le noir tu peux plus du tout tu as plus
d'activité tu as plus rien
donc même si il peut venir jouer ce
genre de position il pourra jamais
gagner donc c'est dans tous les cas plus
agréable pour cependant
mais bon dans ce petit jeu de malade
quoi que tu sais Nostradamus me disais
que tu n'es pas une de ces grandes
forces et c'est une petite différence
qu'il avec Maxime et qu'il était très
bon pour les petites poussettes
stratégique quand il était un peu mieux
avec petit avantage
ça fait partie de mon corps
alors est-ce que est-ce que
est-ce qu'il avait
ne pauvre
s'il avait pas sa base malheureusement
pour ma sœur on va pas aller bien loin
ça peut être une ça peut être une partie
Soporifik
on peut repartir sur une petite droit
un peu dommage en arrêter de dire que
mon micro marche pas en fait c'est
incroyable le chat est insupportable en
fait je sais bien que j'étais en micro
pour pourboire
vois tu vois il envoie vite cavalier
donc
Ouais assurance a perdu blabla
ça peut être ça peut être bluff
beau visuellement en tout cas si ça joue
pour
les ordis c'est plus compliqué
mémo du coup on va faire ça en parce que
parce que vraiment visuellement c'est
pas mal
mais est-ce que est-ce que c'était pas
mieux commencer par cavalier a fait un
cavalier G3 c'est pas visuellement c'est
mieux pour pour les blancs quand même
plus agréable ah bah c'est sûr
le plan est clair cavalier G3 cavalier
F5
ouais
on va aller vers F5 et après taper sur
sur les cases blanches éventuellement
avec
voir cavalier le 3 je sais pas
tu vas jouer quoi cavalier recette là
c'est quoi c'est les couilles main
Cavalli normal 3
g65 quand même nom donc ça c'est la
première variante qui regarde mes gosses
est-ce qu'il peut pas jouer à 6h
il faut ici pour échanger
tu chasse le cavalier admettons un petit
fou ce signe quoi par exemple il a quand
même organiser ses pièces
devient
impossible
mais non mais là ça va jouer vraiment
[Musique]
ok par contre ils ont raison j'ai oublié
la pub à qui on parle des chèques on
parle des chèques et les plus part pas
passe un très très gros n'oublie pas qui
est oui j'étais très très bien quand
j'ai pris 9 pubs
les envoie
heureusement que le chat est là-bas qui
a bah sinon on serait pas bien lors de
la pub
après après c'était un bon moment pour
la mettre et du coup tout le monde a la
pluie ou pas je crois que c'est au
hasard ça clique c'est pour ça que je
l'aime autant il y a dû cliquer au
hasard sur la pub donc en fait du coup
je t'envoie la pub mais on est quand
même ce me ce me live en fait ça dépend
pour qui pour qui on sait pas comment ça
marche en a qui en prennent 9 d'autres 1
2 3 donc tu sais pas vraiment
[Musique]
magnifique
un document je propose que tu mettes
pendant 1h d'affilée les pubs en fait
pour être bien sûr que tout le monde à
l'approche de Noël ça marche un petit
peu comme ça
qui sont
[Musique]
de Noël
pour
la Coupe du monde parce que
ça fait plaisir
donc j'étais pas très bien mais c'était
quand même
après ça dépend moi tant que c'est entre
30 secondes et une minute de pub ça va
quand il y a 3 minutes de plus ça me
rend fou 30 secondes oui non mais là
quand j'ai vu je te l'ai envoyé parce
que quand même c'est beau
les pubs qui bug ça fait plaisir à part
le bug de la pub d'ailleurs qui part à
mais tu as encore le son donc tu as le
son du commentaire que tu regardais le
son de la pub en même temps c'est pas
mal là tu restes
mais moi je sens que ça va être pression
pour pour Magnus pour tourner poco sur
Magnus il faut deux trois coups précis
de précis
c'est drôle mais nous faut une petite
erreur
il faut il doit il faut une petite faute
ou entrer une imprécision pour que ça
joue
mais après c'est sûr que il a le foot
casse blanche qui est meilleur le
cavalier F1 qui est pour l'instant
meilleur que le cavalier C6
la meilleure parce qu'il va arriver en
G3 tout de suite il a un temps de retard
pas le cavalier
dans le noir on a peut-être on a
peut-être un tempo un tempo et demi plus
mais la position elle est tellement
fatigue ça joue peut-être pas pour
beaucoup
il va falloir réfléchir maintenant avec
femme non on réfléchis à ce qu'on va
dire le soir dans le résumé
là tu as décidé pour le résumé de ce
soir
Bah pour l'instant on est pas mal
on est pas mal on laisse l'ordi
réfléchir réussi à faire 17 minutes de
vidéo sur la partie d'hier
17 minutes l'objectif c'est quoi ce soir
12h15 et 20h si on veut mais quand les
les parties sont complexes mais je sais
pas comment on a fait 17 ans on s'est
dit on va essayer de raconter plus de
choses qu'il y a pas grand-chose dans la
partie en soit je sais pas on est parti
sur du n'importe où n'importe quand on
est parti sur des explications un peu
plus à théorie qu'on a fait 17 mois là
on les a sur sur l'ouverture ok s'il a
joué contre
qui il joue H3 c'est une espagnole qui a
l'air un peu amélioré pour les blancs on
a vu que les 4
c'était plus ou moins forcer pour
profiter un minimum de la tour B8
qui les deux qui devait jouer des cinq
un peu dans l'esprit du Marchal que là
il a joué ça va dépendre de ces
prochains coup mais si on sait pas en
fait
il est pas très complexe elle est
logique le pion prends une quatre food
et si c'est logique le dessin qui est
logique tous les coups sont magiques
donc on a même pas besoin on a presque
pas besoin de vérifier à l'ordi
le résumé avant
la
j'ai pas j'ai pas compris la phrase non
en fait on a le résumé de la partie dans
une analyse on fait un mega résumé
Ouais mais celle-là en plus on peut pas
trop se tromper je pense que je vais
mais je vais laisser réfléchir l'ordi à
la place de dames c'est deux parce que
c'est peut-être le seul coup blanc qui
est pas sûr à mon avis
où il y avait peut-être
peut-être réfléchir un peu plus à ce
moment-là
à ton micro on peut partir
je suis pas bien avec sa
tata
qui protège de l'autre côté mais non
mais
là ça va mieux
[Musique]
façon tu sais que m'appeler ça ben ouais
mais par contre je crois que là il bosse
c'est mon grand avantage maintenant bah
qui c'est que il y a plein de choses à
faire mais je ne sais rien faire
c'est un truc qu'on devait faire
ensemble mais j'ai déjà fait mais bon je
ne peux pas bon ce terrible
j'arrête de message à Vlad qui m'écrit
yoyo demain si tu veux refaire le Nostra
Vaduz j'ai un truc à faire à 20h à
Moscou
donc soit on commence plus tôt ce on
commence on se contente de 55 minutes si
on commence plus tard
[Musique]
tu écris yoyo la fine fleur
je réponds je réponds
yoyo la fine fleur
tu finis à quelle heure
j'ai un truc à 20h et je vais lui dire
et je vais rajouter un truc
c'est bien très bien
ah bah oui
et oui pas le choix bah qui est très
bien
c'est des coups trop logique
ah ça sent ça sent pas bon pour mettre
des shop
c'est déjà sympa mais je crois que oui
il y a des possibilités que la pendule
ne part pas non plus
et peut-être même pas les pièces
mais on va laisser un petit peu à me
récupérer mastiquer
dans quel est le 53 d'ailleurs tu m'as
déjà répondu je sais mais j'en profite
pour pour lui redemander
pauvre
ta part est pas mal
mais
c'est peut-être le
moment n'était pas sûr
il environ 2000 mois j'aurais mis un
petit peu plus tu vois
et t'inquiète pas mal en 2000 c'est pas
mal
2000 c'est pas mal
encore une mauvaise game non pas
vraiment là c'est une game plutôt
intéressante pour le moment tout de même
mais ça va se décider dans les dans les
prochains coups et on peut ne pas
ça peut devenir une belle comme c'est
pas
terrible mais je crois que tu
lui manques je pense que
il a besoin d'un peu tout petit peu
mieux c'est
Magnus comme tu dis il est trop fort
dans ses positions là
il faut avoir un peu plus que
la la réflexion s'il avait pas d'âme ces
deux
qui peut pas gagner de position mais
c'est le problème contre Magnus c'est
qui va lui faire tout les Espagnols si
se fait pas vraiment attraper dans
l'ouverture il va les tenir Magnus Noël
mais est-ce qu'il va avoir envie de ça
tout dépend fait pour Yann c'est
vraiment les noirs qui sont qui sont
déterminantes imagine regarde
aujourd'hui si ils font la danse dans
la demi-heure ou dans leur l'approche
genre de repos la prochaine Magnus blanc
imaginons de nouveau il refait la même
qu'hier
est-ce que tu penses qu'il va rejouer
encore au Cateau 5 un moment il va
s'énerver un peu quand même
plus tous les championnats du monde il a
jamais montré
contre
Vichy c'est clair oui
il a peut-être envie de montrer un petit
peu plus quoi
à quelle heure après une partie sur les
26 dernières parties de championnat du
monde et oui c'est
tranquille il s'en fiche ça lui fait
5625 ça commence à faire un peu trop
ouais c'est vrai que ça fait beaucoup
on ne dit en fait tu es passé à la radio
avec tu es comme avec FAP sur Inter bon
ok c'était très tôt mais c'est cool en
podcast sur les échecs tout ça fait
plaisir
jouer 10 parties
insipide pour Halloween sur les 4
dernières non mais moi je suis plutôt
d'accord avec ce que disait Étienne tout
à l'heure si ça commence à all-in sur
les 4 dernières ça va être à l'avantage
de de Yann parce que les le prix d'un
coup ce sera plus élevé et peut-être que
c'est Manu ce qui se retrouvera vraiment
sous pression je pense que là c'est le
meilleur segment de marches pour Magnus
la rentrer la partie 4 et 8 c'est pour
ça je pense si la prochaine il a pas de
poussette il va changer
parce que même une partie comme
aujourd'hui là il a un peu de chance je
pense que
que Yann il soit plus dense après parle
en vrai que le foot et 6 logique et pas
été dans
cette une erreur des secondes en
non mais bon c'est pas facile tu sais tu
te souviens pas parce que on peut pas on
peut pas savoir
non mais des fois pas de chance tu vois
c'est pas le truc que tu as révisé et
qu'il a révisé peut-être une semaine du
coup qui souviens pas des micros détails
mets
ça me fait penser un peu à ce à quoi
il faut le beau lui et oui parce que oui
non mais si ça tombe
il est tombé vraiment dans le truc qu'il
avait révisé qui sait ça pourrait tomber
ok tu as la même chose côté blanc et que
côté noir il est un peu moins à l'aise
ça peut
est-ce que tu joues cavalier G6 est-ce
que tu trouves que finalement ça en
revanche pour le spectacle c'est pas un
petit peu dommage que les ouvertures et
pris autant de poids je parle côté
spectateur je parle pas en tant que
c'était mais ça a toujours été comme ça
en fait là c'est jamais a du monde c'est
une personne contre une et ça se limite
je sais plus si tu te souviens par
exemple et quand tu es à l'erreur
ça se joue à une micro à 5 minutes qui
était hyper intense
même ou même sur la fin du match dans
cette il y avait une berlinoise à la fin
ou Vichy la joie le B5 ai pensé qu'il
pouvait presque gagné reviens ce soir et
puis se fondre un moment mais du coup ça
joue sur des sur une demi-heure quoi des
concentrations une faute ou un manque
d'attention ou sur le mot né rattraper
mais forcément quand tu as qu'une partie
en jeu tu peux mal tomber
mais les matchs reste très intéressant
après on a de la chance on a quand même
on a pas de chance c'est pas Maxime mais
on a de la chance ça soit quelqu'un qui
quand même on voit qui qui va donner un
peu de fil à retordre un champion du
monde on est un peu inquiet comme avant
le début du match et là je suis plus
inquiète
j'ai jamais été vraiment inquiète non
après c'est sûr que par exemple le père
la première partie c'est fini mais comme
Caruana en fait
il était a moins 5 dans la première
partie
il fait peur Magnus mais bon il trouve
qui joue quand même clairement en
dessous en match de championnat du monde
par rapport à son à son jean au tournoi
Ouais mais si tu regardes tu vois il
joue plein d'ouverture mais il joue
jamais content de Maxi bien préparé
quand je rentre à la demande
toujours en temps on a tellement bien
préparé quand je mets du monde
appartement Dépôt il fait du sport tous
les jours il doit réviser cinq six heure
par jour il a travaillé 6 mois pour ce
match là ah oui il arrive
pas à le battre
les blancs touché par contre il va pas
faim
c'est pas pareil c'est pas le même
niveau d'implication c'est pas les mêmes
prépa c'est là il a combien il a investi
sur sa prépa n'est pas
sur sur sur sur sa prépa pour ce matin
financièrement à un demi-million à mon
avis minimum minimum minimum
minimum
donc ça te dit ou quoi
c'est sûr que quand
content
par exemple pour des joueurs comme moi
c'est difficile de jouer
moi encore parce que je travaille
mais pour enfant pour un joueur par
exemple comme Douda qui a pas de qui a
quand il joue ce mec-là c'est dur pour
lui et ben oui parce que parce que des
mecs qui ont moi je vais jouer les
Grands Prix feed je les mecs qui en plus
de chance de se qualifier ils ont centre
200000 parents pour se préparer et
encore voilà voilà c'est minimum ils ont
au moins 102 ans donc après oui c'est
dur de toucher fin
de la guerre de toute façon après
toute l'année
et
c'est vrai
mais tu sais pense il a le temps de
penser que aux échecs il y a trois
quatre mecs qui s'occupe de ses prépa il
a plus qu'à regarder ben oui mais ça ça
me fait penser un petit peu à la Formule
de ce côté-là parce que la Formule 1
celui qui a la meilleure voiture bon
c'est les meilleurs pilotes qui ont les
meilleures voitures c'est c'est normal
mais ça leur donne un double avantage
déjà ils sont un peu plus fort et en
plus ils ont la meilleure voiture ils
ont l'habitude de gagner et il y a plein
de plein de choses qui rentre en plus
d'argent plus
que le petit avantage fixe un tout petit
peu plus fort de base en fait ça
[Musique]
ça existait tu payes tout oui non et
c'est comme clash royale
non mais ça augmente des chances mais
c'est sûr c'est sûr de non mais on peut
pas lutter tu vois un joueur 2007 je
vais prendre n'importe qui s'en prendre
à me prendre par exemple Iakovenko
Beaujoire
qualifié pour Grand Prix qu'est-ce qu'il
fait qu'est-ce qu'il dépense 55000 pour
avoir trois quatre mecs et le prépare
pour la Bresse qu'il arrive il vous est
petit truc et puis tu arrives tu veux
tes petits trucs parce que tu passes de
3 % à 4 % de 4 alors que l'autre il
passe de 25 à 40 et
non mais c'est normal c'est tout à fait
normal et avec son
oui là c'est d'ici là ils ont que pour
ce match là il a les mêmes moyens que
Magnus pour se préparer et et en plus
quand tu vas jouer rien donné. Est-ce
que tu penses que ces prochains temps va
il va je croyais que Petrov
voilà il a pas envie non il a pas envie
de travailler 5h par jour pour faire que
des nuls avec le noir non ça m'intéresse
pas ça m'intéresse personne mais pour un
champion du monde il est capable de
faire ça comme c'est pas les mêmes les
mêmes trucs donc est-ce qu'il y a un
petit peu oui mais
est-ce qu'il y a un peu probable
il a aussi plus d'adversité quoi
tout simplement j'aime bien la
différence des explications entre Nostra
vladu c'est toi c'est toi c'est très
posé rationnel il est notre Abla du CO
il s'est un petit slip
on l'a plus d'ailleurs on l'a perdu
[Rires]
non mais c'était hyper intéressant mais
j'étais en train de me dire ça quand je
t'ai écouté
c'est pas possible
mets un moment un moment il peut craquer
ouais ça fait beaucoup de nul d'affilée
quoi pour pour Magnus non mais c'est
intéressant ce que tu dis que c'est dur
parce que tu vois de nous voir amateur
quand je vais jouer je vais cliquer là
je vais plus jouer mais quand je vais
jouer j'ai envie de faire envoie quoi
mais en fait tu as du mal avec un
amateur à te projeter sur le fait que
c'est ennuyeux aussi pour les pro de
faire des parties
il se passe rien
c'est pour ça regarde maintenant
j'ai plus envie de
toi
oui mais bon ouais non mais d'accord
mais quand tu veux vraiment des
résultats sur le long terme non mais tu
sais quoi
j'étais déjà moins un moment j'étais
très bon j'étais aussi sponsorisé par
contre
après j'ai investi c'est mon argent
propre
par rapport aux autres voilà regarde
celui qui fait actuellement c'est
parce que
[Musique]
c'est
dur de rattraper des problèmes tu as pas
envie d'être trop tu fais quoi
le problème
[Musique]
non mais mais je veux dire par là que
c'est intéressant que j'ai c'est
difficile psychologiquement aussi de te
voir faire ça tu as pas envie c'est pas
quelque chose que tu as envie de faire
mais quand je veux vraiment pour le
résultat des fois tu as pas tu as pas le
choix
réveil non c'est
les boîtes des fois tu as pas le choix
c'est vrai que c'est difficile et là sur
un match comme ça ça dure 3 semaines tu
dois pas t'amuser tous les jours devant
les pieds tu as passé beaucoup de temps
à réviser et cetera c'est vrai que ça
doit au bout d'un moment tu dois en
avoir marre quoi tu peux pas tenir tu
peux pas tenir le
pont là tu peux pas le tenir sur sur 6
mois à tenir sur 60 parties coiffeur
impossible
valeur Karpov Kasparov au bout d'un
moment merci messieurs on arrête E53 ça
suffit on joue un match de zéro
non
est-ce que l'argent joue tant que sont
les échecs 3 vous écoutez c'est le nerf
de la guerre comme dans toutes
disciplines sportives au final tu prends
le foot c'est celui aussi les clubs qui
ont les meilleurs centres de formation
les meilleurs installation
c'est ça ça joue à un jeu par exemple
il commence à avoir un petit peu plus
sérieuse
ça lui fait ça en fait il a fait un step
up
impression ça te fait passer de la 8e 9e
place mondiale à 3/4 pareil
quand ça marche bien oui c'est tu fais
plus peur tu y a toi et puis j'imagine
que c'est plus facile on va prendre
l'exemple de duda c'est plus facile
d'aller voir aujourd'hui on sort en
disant je joue les candidats dans 6 mois
je peux jouer le match pour le titre que
avant qui dit oui bon ben je suis
pas du tout le même storytelling pour le
sponsoring donc ça donne des moyens pour
se préparer et c'est un peu le cercle
vertueux dans ton parler
la Magnus qui souffre un petit peu
qu'est-ce que ce cavalier G6
il faut trouver la Kika tempo
voir venir un peu
il y a des choses qui ont changé la
toi déjà
Jacques cavalier recette c'était pas
après réflexion c'était pas le
dans le top des coups
cavalier G6
tous les sports individuels en fait si
tu as investi plus tu peux attendre plus
en retour et plus tu es bankable puis on
s'intéresse à toi et on te propose des
sponsors et tout ce qui s'ensuit c'est
exactement ça c'est exactement ça donc
là la turbine elle nous dit quoi nous
Dick
côté Magnus les écailles qui sucent
ouais ah d'accord parce qu'en fait il y
a les deux C4 C5 qui arrive aussi
maintenant
donc elle nous donne dans certaines
variant de cette idée
nous dit quoi
elle nous dit que peut-être le meilleur
coup c'est dam 7 cavaliers F5 dame de 8
ans pour te dire
que ça commence à suer un petit peu là
il est très très bien
moi je commence un petit peu à
tout moment
répondez-moi
là ça commence à tuer pour maquille donc
il a joué il a quand même jouer les les
plus naturelles
et là où elle idées C4 C5 elle et elle
peut être embêtant tu
ouais c'est ça que ça peut ça peut
partir salon l'avais pas du tout de base
non ouais
en fait j'ai pas pensé ah ouais ben tu
mets le G3 pour aller à
regarder même faut aussi ça avait l'air
d'aller pour les Noirs mais fou et 3
c'est un bon coup là il y a pas de souci
c'est vidament tout à l'heure on gagne
un tempo sur le cavalier la faut aussi
se fout prends puis on prend ces quatre
c'est déjà fini en fait
c'est marrant parce qu'il devait être au
courant des idées n'est pas il a pas eu
lors de coup parce que le foot et si
c'était pareil mais finalement ça a dû
peut-être que dans ces calculs tellement
qu'il y a 7 g si c'est naturel il s'est
peut-être dit parce qu'en fait il devait
jouer fou 17 ou un truc comme ça
c'est
pas bien
parce que
on va voir ce
terrible j'ai envie de te dire on en
saura plus après la pub
désolé mais j'ai après j'oublie non
c'est parfait c'est parfait de toute
façon il y a peut-être deux personnes
sur toi qui nous entendre encore on sait
pas complètement mais du coup j'ai coupé
sur le C4 C5 que tu sais ce que j'y
pense je vois ça
ouais parce que si on joue ces quatre et
que les Noirs joue c'est 5e même le fou
des 6 va être vraiment très mauvais et
le foot B3 qui va taper sur C4 il peut
aller quand même en a quatre mais il
peut aller récupérer récupérer il y a
pas de sourcils Paris va bien ouais il y
a des tours qui peuvent partir collana
ça commence ouais
j'avais pas j'avais pas
oublié
donc si vraiment on va on va si on
réussi à avoir les yeux de lynx
il lui reste 1h car 1h40 à la pendule
est juste ici que c'est pas tant que ça
non parce que il y a 21 coups à faire ça
fait une heure il est la moitié de son
temps il a pas les 30 secondes je le
rappelle
et il a utilisé la moitié de son temps
pour même pas la moitié des coups plus
il a joué Wiko 2010 pouces en jouet
exactement et il y a la fatigue aussi
non Étienne qui s'accumule à force de
réfléchir comme ça ça je me rends pas
compte physiquement toi par contre une
partie de 17h mais c'est pas c'est pas
que c'est pas que la partie où il y a la
préparation là je pense que personne ne
se rend compte de ce qui se passe avant
ah bah il y a quoi il y a 4 ans
je sais pas ça dépend en fait du des
joueurs de des parties et tu vois je me
rappelle quand j'étais avec Sacha tout
ce qu'il avait à réviser il arrive à
réviser avant les parties mais pendant
tu vois pendant ces candidats là il
était tout son énergie quoi il devait
pas être dire la fin
même
la pour un championnat du monde
donc
Magnus Magnus en sûr c'est peut-être
après la partie numéro 2 du match la
partie la plus intéressante un pour le
moment Étienne avec avec une une vraie
pression mise à part par l'un des deux
joueurs de nouveau au blanc aux échecs
se sont les joueurs avec les pièces
blanches qui sont en capacité de mettre
leurs adversaires en difficulté vu qu'il
commence la partie. Ça aurait pu se
terminer très vite en fait mais il a
joué le naturel trop vite cavalier G6 ça
il a oublié un peu ouais faut trois qui
rajoute cette idée C4 C5 là il vient de
se rendre compte en fait
j'avais pas sur la vraie pas facile tu
vois moi je regarde un peu même si je
suis pas hyper concentrée tu vois c'est
des trucs qu'on peut
et donc là il est il est un peu en
souffrance parce que
en vrai par exemple si il fait cavalier
F4 peut-être qu'il pense à cavalière
cadre
il peut penser à s'activer à et à jouer
de
sacrifier où a essayé de mettre des pots
sous pression comme on l'a vu la souvent
quand même d'essayer de téléphone de
manière très active mais est-ce qu'il
pleut ici alors est-ce que par exemple
si il fait cavalier F4 l'idée c'est ça
serait quoi
si c'est une idée
et là par exemple sur voilà par exemple
sur Tours
ad15 en vrai dans cette maison un coup
comme ça
il y a trop trop trop
[Musique]
regarde par exemple
dam dam dam C8 pour éviter que c'est 6
cavaliers j'ai 6 sur 8 et là faut
prendre cette apprendre à ma de maths. À
tout bientôt ma jolie c'est très joli
thématique thématique
de la montre et
on a le temps dans le cavalier f48
plutôt pas du coup
mais du coup si tu as pas cavalier F4 tu
as pas fou aussi c'est parce que vous
aussi vous prend aussi si on prend le 6
on a la position quand j'ai regardé tout
à l'heure avec deux tempo de moi la C4
C5 c'est terrible
quoi d'autre quoi qu'est-ce qu'on peut
jouer la la turbine elle propose de
nouveau mais bon ça tu as pas envie food
et c'est peut-être se développer
peut-être fou 17 rue des Dames à 8 tu as
vraiment pas envie de
la colonne des turbines te donne
quasiment quasiment seul coup par contre
il y a probablement c'est quoi trop
ça c'est quoi trop
même en sachant qu'on n'oublie surtout
que la préfou 17 tu vois c'est cinko
10 ans noir
AD1 j'imagine il y a du d'imbécile
peut-être mais là ils ont toujours eu
des seins
là on a l'impression que c'est vraiment
très mauvais
cavalier ou je sais pas tu vas peut-être
fou à Quattro d'abord
la nettoie Quattro j'aime bien en fait
tour des dames c'est 7 fois trop
tard ils vont à la piscine cossy
cavalier cette ça devient quasiment le
seul coup
complexe visuellement très difficile tu
vas peut-être qu'il va faire tu vas pas
rentrer de gaieté de cœur comme comme le
dirai ça dans cette position non non
pour l'instant la turbine qui me donne
dame 7 qui a l'air d'aller encore pour
les Noirs mesdames 7 cavaliers
psychodrame D8 sa personne l'affaire bah
c'est vraiment par
c'est vraiment si tu vois pas de quoi ce
que là tu me menaces peut-être quand
même
je sais pas si toi tu me diras sur toi
demain tu fais quoi est-ce que je vais
te poser la même question
je serai trop savoir sur toi bien tu
fais comme ce que du coup
si tu fais fous prends puis on prend le
car il va bouger il y aura qui les prend
le 5 mai peut-être qu'il va lui prendre
4 incroyable mais c'est trop dur et sur
d'emprunt 4 de taper 3 en l'air et il y
a pas de
mais c'est un peu trop c'est très dur
qui va les prendre 4 à ce moment-là
surtout qu'il peut y avoir des fous
prend F7 intermédiaire de dinde en plus
là
par exemple tu prends des 6
c'est quoi le
terrible qui allait prendre des 6 pour
prendre un assistant encore tu reprends
mes trois
[Musique]
quatre personnes
par contre là
c'est quoi trop
il veut quoi sur C4
C4 c'est pas il est pas bien il est pas
bien Jafar C5 quand même
oui mais tu fais quoi sur des
peut-être venir avec la dame en C6 du
coup
x
401 ans c'est horrible ça va vraiment
pas envie de toi
regarder chaussettes si tu peux même
repartir
cavalier 2 C3 B52 ces 3 dessins du coup
ça fait pas 100 ans
il
faut peut-être
difficile à dire
mais c'est horrible
laisser le 14e comme ça non ça il fera
pas est-ce que tu as un plan ici jusqu'à
me fou c'est un fou d'ailleurs
je pense
que c'est parce qu'il va faire en 1er
mai
mais c'est les mêmes fous célébrer on
dit le fouet horrible avec la tu vas en
Bessin que tu vois en fait ok comme tu
as a aidé lui l'abbé quoi terrible
c'est à Saint des trucs que m'a expliqué
Fab il y a longtemps que j'avais pas
vraiment saisis j'ai bien aimé
communiquer mais en fait les structures
de pions ça joue vraiment sur le
placement de pièces tu peux avoir des
trucs sur symétrique et suivant où les
pièces sont placés les unes par rapport
aux autres ça change absolument tout et
là c'est un excellent excellent exemple
que tu as les deux fous qui sont
pareilles comme tu l'as montré le
premier on dit il est horrible l'autre
l'autre téléphone
mais
pourquoi
après peut-être que par défaut c'est ce
qu'il va faire là il joue des coups par
défaut
visuel mandat c'est un coup par défaut
écoute je pensais la première fois dans
ce match où il y a une position où tu
sens que tu es sûr
j'ai envie de dire presque du 4045
pourcents de chance de victoire l'arbre
est-ce qu' est-ce que c'est pas ma de
Bishop qui aurait
envoyer des ondes est-ce que ce serait
pas mal du chef qui sera en salle de
repos
sur l'écran ça doit être magnifique a
des petites flèches qui doivent partir
ma biche a pas hacker l'ordinateur de la
salle de repos Dépôt il montre les coups
et là sa montre quand même que le que la
tactique d'ouverture de Néo Pau elle est
plutôt pas mal
de fois l'espagnol ça ne va pas mais la
troisième est une très très très bonne
idée
il fallait je vais au moins 3 fois pour
commencer ce match vraiment très très
faim l'entourage de
j'avais prédit
d'ailleurs Booba maman est dans l'équipe
de n'est pas gêné d'un formateur
il va pas être bien au travail si c'est
pas gagné pour aujourd'hui ça va tu es
oui
j'ai toujours su que je devais dire que
ça se passait mal pour qu'il vienne
il envoie les fausses infos en fait quoi
il a toujours en fait
et en plus
c'est pas beaucoup c'est pas beaucoup et
qui reprend
avec
non
je suis pas bien
j'ai pas compris
en tout cas quand une valise en sueur
avec la veste de dépôt ils sont pas bien
fausse AGROLA
moi enfin là c'est faux ça gros qui sue
quand même sur les chéquiers sont pas
bien c'est quoi d'ailleurs faut ça gros
ce sont des engrais
le Monsanto
exactement en fait
Monsanto c'est une copie de phosagro
largement largement
engrais bio je pars de choses
ses sponsors de Néo Pau depuis un
certain moment je crois qu'il a eu déjà
ce sponsor avant les candidats
ils ont été quelques jours
et c'est presque une rose Bakis Taner
non le logo ah oui je pense qu'ils se
sont inspirés
la fine fleur à la fine fleur la fine
fleur
est-ce que tu as vu ce sponsor si ma
langue oui
mais est-ce que c'est lui où est-ce que
c'est
les 8 là il doit être assez content et
là il prend son temps
parce qu'il a pas fait ronde ronde de
passage parce que Jess comme France il
met à quelle n'est pas à avoir le droit
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
et oui une belle journée Twitter pour
ceux qui suivent pas encore lestream Flo
très clair et
une belle réponse
elle répond la définition du marlou des
Andes
[Musique]
bientôt
j'écris un petit peu à Maxime tu vas
peut-être bientôt nous rejoindre mais il
sue
C-Max
envoyer des dauphins il est pas bien max
il est pas libre il est pas libre
[Rires]
dans quoi il réfléchit au bon moment
demain 8 beaucoup de coup là c'est quoi
trop on aime bien c'est quoi toi c'est
vraiment sympa et je pense qu'il l'a vu
ces derniers couilles là c'est quoi trop
ouais parce que alors on a pas il y a un
autre coup c'est toujours bien mais
comme il y a la dame en 8 ans n'a pas
vraiment envie quoi en fait c'est
toujours le coup qu'il attendait que tu
qu'il anticipé quoi il en profite et
la turbine ce qu'elle en pense
c'est quoi trop sur demain 8
dans le jardin et on aimerait pas faire
compliqué oui mais justement cécile a
fait c'est parce que tous les coups de
naturel ne fonctionnait pas donc il est
parti sur la 8 par dépit c'est pas par
choix parce que fou 17 le c'est quoi
trop il tapait C5 mêmes C6 peut-être
après
donc non dans 8 et dames 7 cavaliers 5
dames D8 il a pas pu ça c'est normal
mets la difficulté en plus qu'il a c'est
que le jour où tu fais C4 C5 ça que
cette dame elle va te prendre 1 x 4
encore ça c'est vrai que c'est
elle est vraiment mal placé
il est pas bien on dit Jerry annonce à
zéro
un petit peu tôt encore quand même du
côté du lit
il est où le nez. Impulsif ben écoute je
trouve qu'il est vraiment bien dans son
match en est beau depuis de depuis la
première ça fait longtemps qu'on l'a
perdu
il faut se souvenir des candidats quand
même
des solides à la deuxième des parties
des candidats il était pas si solide
mais il était déjà il a l'air déterminé
bien plus tranquille aujourd'hui
il est concentré ici c'est qu'il a une
une belle chance la sur pas la gaspiller
faut mettre pression aujourd'hui si mais
pas pression aujourd'hui ouais ça va
être
et c'est là où la couleur elle joue
beaucoup hein parce qu'il avait pas
l'air si déçu après la ronde de
noir
mais c'est le psychologie qu'en fait
mais là il faut qu'il mette faut qu'il
mette pression après il peut ne pas
gagner mais si mais pas pression ça va
être terrible psychologiquement ça après
un coup comme d'hab 8
on aurait aimé un peu déjà rempli
impulsif en deuxième partie des
candidats et surtout à l'avant-dernière
ronde parce que contre Maxime il a très
bien joué il y avait sorti une grosse
partie mais tous les candidats toute la
deuxième partie des candidats ils
étaient
il a vraiment ce côté de déterminer tu
ressens qu'il a changé
d'ailleurs il avait gagné le championnat
de Russie avant les candidats
il enchaîne quand les grandes
performances et tu sais qu'il a lancé
il a lancé certaines Olympiades au
une très belle partie
ok ok
ça quand même tu reviens tu vois c'était
l'autre coup par rapport à ces quatre et
là et on
sait pas mais c'est juste
visuellement quoi mais C4 moi j'aimais
bien
oui ouais
alors c'est quoi la différence c'est
quoi la 10
8 il avait pas le C4 ça c'est dommage tu
reviens
W
ils disent que c'est c'est même pas du
tout
ah ouais ben oui parce qu'il va jouer
faut aussi ça
il faut ici C4 il y a plus il y a du
charisme c'est ça
ah oui il y aura plus fous à quatre
c'est ça la différence c'est que en fait
si tu veux c'est 4 dames c'est si tu
avais le fou à Quattro gagné
alors attends regarde ont quand même sur
C4 pourquoi pas fou au 6
là c'est vrai déterminé mais
[Musique]
et maintenant il faut aussi et sur ses
kadam ses 6
ans et 4
ah ouais pas terrible Baki ouais pas
déterminé n'est pas toujours aussi
impulsif
j'ai plus de batterie en plus
alors attends on va pouvoir te brancher
derrière
on est bien bac ES
ça c'est un peu dommage c'est quand même
une faute étrange parce que c'est que
comme on disait l'autre dame 8 ils ont
fait le tour des en quoi non mais c'est
ça l'autre question est-ce que il a joué
fou et 3 pour ces quatre il y avait pas
du tout le C4 c'est pas compliqué
c'est pas possible qu'il y a des erreurs
comme ça à chaque fois
c'est bon
je crois qu'il y a quelqu'un qui va pas
être content
un joueur à peu près de 1000 ou un peu
plus que 2000
c'est pas possible
non non là ça va là tu as aucun risque
il y a aucun respect
mon chat a un peu à tout moment
Michel peux à tout moment tout cassé tu
es mal
tu te remets bien voilà tu es parfait
Ouais mais décevant décevant Dépôt
C4
maintenant il y a plus rien non
quand même x 4 encore
est-ce que ça peut faire soit 4 ou 17
fois aussi fou fou gay 3 x 6
ans enfin là on va peut-être je vais en
prendre 5
c'est un peu moins bien sur les photos
mais c'est quand même cool pour pour les
blancs
ouais bah c'est cat c'était énorme
chanson dommage c'est combien les Vals à
peu près 60 60 € 60
qui se mérite et c'était mérite et en
plus ça se voyait
x 4 jouets mais ça c'est quoi c'est
combien ça il a dû louper je sais pas ce
qu'il a loupé il faut à Cassis là je
vais rapidement donc c'est qu'il avait
le faut aussi ça
ressemble un tout petit peu mieux pour
le blanc quand même
mais bon on a changé tour des seins pour
ouais c'est bizarre là il y a tous les
coups là en fait
tu imagines tu avais la tour avec
vis-à-vis sur la dame
qu'est-ce qu'il a pu louper il a loupé
quoi ces 4 x 6 x 4 c'est 6 peut-être
qu'il a loupé quelque chose là-bas
peut-être on peut regarder ça ce que tu
veux dire
4 x 6 x 4 x 6
MC-5
ah ouais ça sent que c'est 4 avec un
content Ouais mais il y a des deux ça
ouais parce que c'est 6 qui est qui
reste faible
quand même
je suis souvent dans la reine je l'ai
prise et cavalier F5 mais bon c'est pas
mais est-ce que c'est pas ça en fait
après tu me diras là il fait quoi il
fait ses 8 ou 17 / que c'est petit
avantage blanc
où ça y ressemble en tout cas ici il
fait dame C8 peut-être C4 non non non
non
mais ça reste une pause mais bon ça
reste quand même sympa à vrai dire
attention quand même à pas te faire
enfermer en des 5
on verra en tout cas j'aime bien les
blancs en fait c'est peut-être qu'on a
un petit peu aussi influencé par les
eval parce que quand tu as cette pause
ouais mais c'est oui non mais c'est on
voit que c'est plus agréable d'ailleurs
depuis le début de la partie
mais on sent que c'est quand même un peu
que ces quatre c'était quand même bien
mieux tout à l'heure je peux pas retirer
un vis-à-vis comme ça même si la colonne
est fermé pour l'instant c'est le cheval
qui arrive en F5 F4 qui ouvre à tout
moment
c'est un peu bizarre
mais je veux dire par là quoi qu'il en
est la partie n'est pas finie
quoi qu'il en soit c'est sympa pour
c'est sympa pour dépose cette pause
l'Emmaüs est rassuré de Tours
visuel c'est visuel
bizarre c'est quoi
en fait il joue tous les deux des coups
les coups naturel quoi il va jouer à la
Magnus il a joué au foot et cette
logique
on s'arrête vous prendre à me prendre et
ses 4
faut prendre ça peut être cavalier
prends aussi d'ailleurs
parce que il s'est ouvert la caisse de 6
pour la dame par exemple prends quel est
prends qui a 5 dames à 6
si je dis à moins qu'il y a un tour à
6h sympa
c'est quoi trop
j'avais pas c'est pas vrai il faut
regarder mais c'est quand même ouvert
cette casse quoi
est-ce qu'il va pour demain prendre
cette dame c'est Cissou cavalier prends
prends ça lui il a aussi du cavalier 5
pouces et 5 par exemple il faut regarder
quoi
une bêtise quand même
info
j'ai pas trouvé moi mais je pars là faut
faire un
peu regarder il va regarder tout les
options koala
il va prendre en 17 tu vas pas faire fou
B3
il peut réfléchir à c'est quoi trop tout
de suite aussi mais après la dame vient
la tour en a quatre elle va être un peu
non il va il va prendre 17
c'est sûr qu'il va prendre 17
mais ouais ça fait deux quand il est
très proche de l'avantage c'est deuxième
fois qui quand il a 1h30 il a du mal à
bien prendre son temps pour clutch
pour t'envoyer réfléchir un mais c'est
pas facile
après la raison de rester sur son jeu
son je sais jouer vite bon il prend
quand même plus son tant qu'il ne le
fais parfois après
tu joues toujours à 2850
il a jamais été 28 exemples là il est en
pleine progression c'est pas quel moment
il s'arrête mais
discours que dans ce moment il y a
beaucoup beaucoup d'occasions manquées
c'est normal par le truc c'est que nous
on analyse aussi avec les turbines
Megaforce donc forcément
c'est plus facile dans dans dans le
ciel avec des turbines qui joue à 3800
ans
[Rires]
dépôt
ah mais prends 17 quand même vrai mais
là c'est pas en fait c'est pas normal de
réfléchir maintenant c'est ça qui est
embêtant c'est pas le bon le bon tempo
de réflexion une petite pub avant le
coup de dépôt
sa part
ça fait du bien reines che
ils sont par les Américains soit petit
canapé la reine je crois c'est
et Fabiano
ils ont fait une faute marrante hier
soir ils ont eu le
le correcteur d'orthographe qui a fait
une erreur ils ont mis World
Championship of est
le titre de la vidéo ça ça fait une
erreur ma force d'écrire d'écrire Robert
ça ça comme titre
c'est marrant comme comme erreur moi
j'ai mon correcteur qui met sur tout le
temps au lieu de que c'est tout le temps
c'est
ça
surtout surtout connu pour être le
finaliste de la du blé de Invitational
contre toi
tu lui avais fait mal on visa laisse pas
finaliste quand même j'ai cru qu'il y
aurait 3,7 dans ce match mais j'ai bien
fermé la porte au grand dam dans
certains ministre
oui j'avais misé sur Robert
il est sympa ce Robert moi j'aime
beaucoup c'est c'est commentaire
il est parti non il raconte pas
n'importe quoi pour un américain surtout
un peu péjoratif de dire ça mais il est
pas dans le tu vois dans l'excès
constant des des des des commentateurs
américain il est dans la réalité des
choses et ça fait ça fait plaisir
le petit pays Rennes skipper qui part
pendant la pub
envoie du S aussi parfait ça fait
longtemps que j'ai pas vu l'ambulance
elle passe pas par pas elle part pas ce
soir ce soir ce soir pour être pour
le nouveau je sais pas où elle est
pas du tout ah oui
je peux essayer de la faire partir je
voudrais la faire partir pour
comment il s'appelle
une petite
le x 4
[Rires]
ah non tu mets 3 x 4 il est pas bien 3 x
mais là il y aura pas faux mais 3 x 4
non je pense pas
l'arbitre qui se balade
l'arbitre il est très rapide en à la fin
des parts immédiatement il remet les
pièces il est où tout de suite il perd
pas de temps quoi
Night and
il n'est pas il s'est trompé il s'est
trompé ça se voit
mais dommage en coup le prix d'un coup
ça fait deux fois
non c'est pas un coup en fait c'est sur
une partie
même après V pub n'est pas on n'a pas
joué on associe le vélo un coup
bah là c'est qui loupe c'est la deuxième
fois qui loupé des moments critiques du
match
là c'est sûr que si l'envoie le
par exemple j'ai 5 dames j'essaie tout
le le C4 aujourd'hui
ah ça change tout G5 G7 il était
vraiment trouvable en plus il a pas
chercher là il va pas chercher
est-ce qu'on tente de petit avantage de
petits trucs mais faut aller chercher
plus loin des fois
où il attend le bon moment quoi pour
frapper
quel est l'air déçu en regarde
ouais je sais pas ce qu'il a loupé
est-ce qu'il a pas loupé vous 17 vous
prend ils ont dame C4 mc-6 C5
c'est ça qui veut pas jouer ou quoi
ça c'est le truc le plus logique a le
plus nerf
tu as quand même envie de jouer non
tu es bien avec le blanc qui a une dame
C4 sur A6 non
prends tes cliques là non
j'ai pas dit le contraire mais j'ai
l'impression que tu as comme ça
c'est tout à fait dans mon style
Ouais mais même si tu le défends la dame
pour
toi tu vas envoyer
après il me doit des 8 et 8 par exemple
ok c'est 4
x 8
1 fois de suite justement tu as tout
raciste ok bonjour juste pour montrer à
mes
[Musique]
oui ça c'est bien pour le blanc ça oui
mais il doit y avoir autre chose
ouais
ça donne comme l'impression de pas être
loin de l'avantage blanc bon en tout cas
faut le temps te faut prendre 17 là
c'est bizarre de réfléchir à
7 jours
c'est vite me 6 x 4 CVT sur fou de cette
réflexion
il va peut-être jouer C4 j'ai
l'impression qu'il part pour du c'est
quoi trop là
là il part
pas dans la bonne direction il y a une
c'est dommage
après c'est plus dur aux échecs de jouer
les coups d'attaque que l'écoute défense
jusqu'à ce que tu aies fait la la
différence en fait
ça dépend pour qui
par exemple Mamed oui oui je pense qu'il
te l'envoie mais par contre si va pas
jouer
les tours à la défense
aujourd'hui les joueurs sont beaucoup
plus à Asilah en face de l'autre que que
lors des autres des autres partis 5 ans
est né peau qui met la pression du coup
et qui est qui est resté plus longtemps
pas forcément Magnus il a pas la même
attitude hein il revient réfléchir sur
l'échiquier beaucoup plus rapidement que
Yann est là c'est des positions ou tu a
aussi beaucoup de possibilités donc
beaucoup d'idées tu as plus
toi c'est mieux d'être là pour pour
essayer d'anticiper un petit peu tu vois
plus de possibilités quoi
surtout tu Magnus il a probablement
louper cette idée de C4 C5 et faux et
trois du coup il reste il va rester
vigilant là
Ouais dans une dans une journée lorsque
tu rates une une idée adverse comme ça
tu es plus inquiet après tu dis à
aujourd'hui j'ai raté un truc peut
potentiellement raté un autre ben il a
loupé en tout cas ça se voyait qu'il a
loupé ça c'est sûr qu'il a loupé il
pensait à toi c'est tranquille après
faut trois il a compris que tu dois
jouer 8 tu es pas bien quoi
prix d'un 8 c'est bien saisi carrément
parce que finalement c'est un coup
bizarre mais c'est celui qui lui a
permis de se remettre sur pied a
provoqué l'erreur de Yann
la bizarre 7h
le stress
commence à jouer
forcément
escape 2 salle de repos séparer où c'est
la même salle de repos c'est sûr que
c'est de se séparer
depuis très longtemps
chacun à sa pièce le Championnat du
Monde Belgique
sais jamais quoi tu m'as pas faire les
poches
un petit truc là
Oui puis même c'est plus logique et
d'avoir ses boissons attitré enfin c'est
truc oui non mais ça me paraît tout à
fait normal donc j'en sais rien mais
j'imagine que quelqu'un qu'on a vu ça
sur sur les vidéos
Yann tu n'as pas mis de caleçon Sardoche
infos sur aujourd'hui
combien de caleçon Sardoche tu en as
qu'un ah tu es pas bien en fait je l'ai
mis deux fois
le garde pour les grands moments mais ça
nous as pas idée par contre a gagné le
match
ah tu es bien en bas je les cadeaux
AutoCAD AutoCAD il ne faut pas laver le
caleçon sinon il perd de sa puissance
après chaque lavage elle nous dit Ludwig
et oui c'est pour ça qu'on le met pas
mais pas il veut pas échangé mais il
trouve pas quelque chose de bien vrai
mais il a laissé passer sa chance il le
comprend maintenant c'est pas facile
psychologiquement
bah il va prendre en 17 un de toute
façon même si il trouve une défense il y
a rien qui paraît vraiment
bon tu peux pas jouer foubet 3 x 6 faut
prendre si c'est pas mieux que vous
prends 17 ans pour prendre et ça a été
quand même
28 tu te remets un peu dans le sens du
jeu tu as Tourcoing
à moins que ça soit cavalier prendre
dans ce qu'il est pas envie mais bon
comme tu as dit qu'il y avait 5 dames
e636
ça fait peur en tout cas tu peux rentrer
dedans et voir ce que l'autre jour
il faut prendre dans prend C4 dame C6 C5
y a un truc qui qui l'aime pas à ce
moment-là je pense que c'est la grande
position
est-ce qu'il aime pas 10 ans tu réduite
autour des 8 comme on a dit et là tu as
dit pour des 8 ans et 4 et Tours à 8 à
Huit
bon après c'est dur de pas aimer parce
que c'est ça va jamais être moins bien
ça va jamais être moins bien on sait
jamais quoi assurance C5 qui peut
devenir vulnérable
prête à être un peu naviguer les
cavaliers par là-bas
Ouais mais là il est en train de
réfléchir est-ce qu' est-ce qu'il joue
vraiment pour pour avoir davantage
Croatie ça se finit en fait 3 x 6 il va
pas faire dans tous les cas tu joues tu
risques pas quand même
Ouais mais enfin pourquoi toujours maman
si tu penses que tu as aucune chance de
gagner
il est pas très bien le foie non ça
m'étonnerait
mais il doit
et ces quatre ça fait pas vraiment de
sens maintenant parce que fou prends à
quatre tu vas pas jouer de la me prends
4 je pense.
il a laissé passer sa chance à ce serait
terrible que ça finisse en turbo droit
ouais tu penses que c'est possible là
maintenant non moi j'y crois pas
on va préparer
tranquillement la
merde tu le résumé
Bah qui commence à croire à la Turbo
d'euros c'est terrible en tout cas elle
a raté ça fait 2 occasion ratée va pas
en avoir des dizaines
Sony occasion
il a loupé aussi de semis occasion
la première qui était clairement une
occasion parce que c'était quand même
pas c'était vraiment sa position dans la
première
il a eu de la chance que ça soit dans la
première qui l'a
[Musique]
vraiment
qui avait ça il autre occasion c'était
la deuxième ou faut trois quatre cinq il
aurait pu poser des problèmes ou mais
c'était pas assez clair quoi faire
ouais c'est des semis occasion c'est
genre foot 1 3 contre 3 un moment donné
où ça se passe tu as l'impression que ça
peut bien se passer tu te raconter quoi
non mais là si si nul aujourd'hui la
prochaine va être très très importante
j'ai envie de te dire c'est un petit peu
à chaque fois qui annule la prochaine
Ouais mais là on sent que que les
parties noires elles sont quand même pas
très agréable pour moi
oui quand tu revois après ok sale
d'avant-hier il a vraiment fait beaucoup
plus d'efforts que mes pots hier
pour le moment même la première
sortie d'ouverture elle était pas ouf
enfin pour moi l'impression que dès
qu'il va réussir à avoir cette sa
position avec les blancs qui va lui
obtenir le petit avantage que qui sera
plus à même de ce qu' est-ce qu'il va
l'obtenir de l'amener au bout
il va répéter c'est terrible tu sais
qu'il va répéter là je sais pas je pense
qu'il va répéter
ok
il prend notre un autre plan quoi mais
on est rassuré
mais par contre la dame elle va être
forte la dame noire elle rentre de la
dame échanger
tu penses que je dois me
prendre pour mettre C45 en fait mais bon
tu vois je veux toujours rester 8 x 8
j'ai pas dit qu'il allait jouer avec qui
qui va pouvoir presser
à mon avis comme Magnus a mis du temps à
lui faire le cavalier 8 cavaliers hier
ça l'a saoule et il a pas envie de faire
couper 3 x 4 et encore une fois du coup
est-ce qu'il avait cette idée C4 C5 et
il a jamais s'il a fait faut 3 pour
qu'il y a des de ces quatre peut-être
Magnus en tout cas lui il a vu ses 4 ans
bien fait mais est-ce que
est-ce que
d'ailleurs j'ai envoyé un petit même
aujourd'hui sur Twitter c'est encore une
mule avant le jour de repos j'ai une
petite idée
mon cavalier de 2 à c'est logique quand
même parce que le cavalier F3 qui était
pas très utile
il va taper
d'ailleurs il peut même préparer C4 C5
sait jamais
cavalier F3 était pas utile en fait mais
si les dames qu'est-ce que ça donne
moi j'ai peur que après pour tu restes
des 8 il faut F8
il y a plus beaucoup de matériel quand
même comme ça
j'arrive pas
tu essayes de faire que tu vas tout
défendre et tout blindé
et j'ai plus de
pièces
je suis pas un joueur d'espagnol bah qui
j'ai jamais joué dans ma vie je connais
que par les parties que je regarde mais
il est très très très peu de faiblesse
oui là
il va jouer à Magnus
il va prendre ça c'est sûr
m'appelle bluff
c'est pris il n'y a pas eu de bœuf
et regarde ce que dit la turbine surtout
reprend à 4 propose tour B2
pour prendre le train à 4h
ok c'est l'heure de préparer voyage aux
dames prends
ouais c'est l'heure de préparer la vidéo
pas
terrible
mais lundi donc on en est accrue un
petit moment un coup
et puis le début non mais le début était
quand même non mais va à l'ouverture est
intéressante et
non mais oui elle loupe et évidemment là
ça va être dur Bodereau mais louper te
reprends à quatre tombé dedans cavaliers
des deux savais pas
enfin c'est pas trop
ce qu'il a loupé ou pas
en obligé il y aura eu un éclair
d'espoir est toujours sur Wii
non mais après de nul c'est pas
c'est pas si mal sur sur ces deux
journées de choses qui ne dit pourquoi
turbo draw
je pense qu'il arrive à Maxime
non non il n'a pas la ref
Maxime n'a pas la Turbo dors ou quoi
il pense que c'est mieux pour le blanc
je pense que ça joue encore mais je
pense que ça va être
la joue il l'a joue les amis
attention ils sont obligés de jouer 5 ou
encore
km
ça ressemble en tout cas
la Manu si on a rien à faire
cavalier c'est quoi trop encore
ça clique ça clique
Ouais mais on va se prendre de cavalière
quatro
je sais pas trop peu de faiblesse
trop une position pour Magnus versus
n'est pas
terrible elle sera le champion du monde
qui réussit pas à prendre de la hauteur
pour le moment il manque il manque ce
petit éclair de génie moi ou cette
petite gaffe quoi
il faut
ah bah demain ça va pouvoir ça va
pouvoir se reposer travailler peut-être
viens avec de nouvelles vidéos blanc en
pour pour Magnus pense qu'il essaie de 4
D4 demain au Barça non ça repart sur des
4 like c'est sûr non c'est 4 ou des 4
Ouais ok 3 mais non tu penses qu'on se
revoit plus jamais du match pour pour
Magnus trop c'était trop fière pour lui
il a senti qui m'aime qui avait les H4
il a c'est que
ils ont fermé le 4 et non après ça
dépend ce si il y a une partie c'est pas
pareil pas pareil donc c'est 00
non je pense que je vais des parties
comme ça ça va l'embêter au bout d'un
moment ça lui plaît pas quoi ouais mais
comme on a dit combien 25 26 partie 27e
nul de fil et on s'en va du monde ok
c'est trop pour un champion du monde
c'est vrai que
cavalier 5 x 7
tu veux l'annuler rapidement non bâti je
sens que bah qui a changé de d'opinion
sur la partie je veux maintenant une
turbo d'euros
c'est un peu ça la force
de succès championnat du monde c'est
qu'au début tu espère une victoire après
quand tu sens que ça va vers la nuit
j'espère que tu as vraiment envie de
faire la nul
baffe
elle va pas être super intéressante quoi
en vrai
du coup petit pub
c'est l'heure de la pub Baki mais
il faut la mettre ton qu'on peut
la prendre mais pas bien
on a un au foot on a instauré la
Victoire à 3 en français des équipages
vers l'avant ah bah oui là en bas le
champion du monde savait que tu as
changé beaucoup de choses si la victoire
était à 3. Bacchi
ah oui c'est un resto il marquerait plus
inverse toujours
voilà faudrait faire 8 cubes ça fait
plaisir on pourrait faire un truc on
pourrait donner le titre de champion du
monde au nom de Victor avec les Blancs
Cerqueux perdreau ne changerai rien au
blanc
que tu fasses ce que tu perds de toute
façon ça changera rien du coup tu
pourrais tout le temps fort c'est comme
un idiot non mais je suis bien d'accord
il y a pas de solution vrai mise à part
les cadeaux de toute façon ça c'est une
autre question
après moi moi je trouve ça bien quand
même
moi je pense que les deux devrait
exister en fait parallèlement une saison
rapide et une saison à Londres en fait
d'enlever le titre de champion du monde
de long en plastique parce que c'est des
bobards c'est sûr que le toujours des
candidats c'est sûr
amusant qu' est-ce que le match en
lui-même
parce que tu as quatre parties quoi
là tu as que une partie
ah bah les candidats puis en plus ces
joueurs doivent se préparer contre cet
adversaire différent nous qui sont quand
j'étais tout petit de 7,8 ans 7 ans
match Kasparov Karpov mettez le weekend
voir une partie évidemment des tombes
sur la sur le double ajournement à
magnifique on a pas vu la fin
mets-moi vous avez vu du jeu
et
je suis tombé sur
[Musique]
le téléphone et
j'arrive à la salle
j'étais dégoûté au début
ben moi je pense qu'il va même pas
essayer en fait mais pour la
il a fait deux tours à 6
il va même pas essayer
j'avais internet sur le tel en 2010
ou alors oui en 2010 non mais je suis
sûr sur le tel
j'ai quasiment sûr d'essayer de regarder
ou alors j'ai essayé j'ai regardé avant
de partir de chez moi en tout cas
j'avais pas les hôtels pendant
oui d'ailleurs c'était pas 2017 en 2012
mais non mais moi il va même pas essayer
pour la donc c'est parti
premier iPhone 2007 oui non mais c'est
sûr que j'avais alors
et puis on suivait pas les vidéos on
juste les parties
si tu te rappelles il avait bien il
avait déjà gagné avant de perdre il a
perdu parce qu'il a gagné en fait il
aurait jamais dû perdre
est-ce que c'est un mauvaise adversaire
c'était sûr qu'il perdrai quand même
parce que il m'avait dit avant le match
canon des amandes et un mauvais match up
pour prendre
du coup il faut que tu as gagné mais je
suis très surpris mais bon tu vas voir
toujours su je connaissais déjà le
résultat avant que ça joue quoi
je crois que c'était Pâques dans le
métro à Moscou tu avais tu étais pas en
3G tu est en Edge donc tu sues est quand
même pour
ça passait pas bien et tu suis bien quoi
donc bac ES
annuler Bonjour Bah presque presque un
coup bah si alors s'il y a une vraie
Oh peut-être croustibat ce soir
peut-être qu'est-ce que tu en dis
qu'est-ce que Lena
on ne va pas jeter
remarque elle est restée que c'est pas
si vous avez un petit peu de citron
franchement ça passe bien pire ça va
tu faisais
à Victoria quand elle était petite
non je faisais pour moi
mets et oui les croustibat qui sont
encore dans le congel Maxime qui qui a
fait une préparation qualitative menacé
la menace est plus forte que l'exécution
mais en vrai ça passe si un jour tu as
vraiment plus rien à manger et qui te
reste les coups si bas dans le congel tu
peux faire le coup si Baptiste a un
petit rond par contre c'est très
important
tout le monde qui va débarquer chez
Maxime pour les croustibat dans le
congel depuis une petite année
quand on est joueur professionnel on
peut remettre en doute sa vie entre deux
variantes pas compris la question
on est un peu trop tranquille pour ça
croustibat micro-ondes non je suis pas
vrai je suis pas prêt
il va se conserver encore une bonne
vingtaine d'années
Ouais mais je sais plus je sais plus
trop quoi dire sur la game il y a plus
beaucoup de pièces comme tu le disais
mais ça peut on peut jouer au
dépôt
ouais
il y a plus de chemise dans le pantalon
il y a plus rien là
est-ce que tu penses toi et la question
est posée et que ce serait bien de jouer
les départage avant le match
non mais là c'est 14 parties il va y
avoir quelque chose qui va se passer
avec un homme
n'est pas il a joué aussi après
évidemment deux trois coups précis c'est
drôle c'est ce qui va arriver oui après
c'est sûr
mais peut-être faire les recettes
culinaires russe
alpha il va falloir que
tu es pas venu à la maison
oui c'est passé quelques petits trucs
entre-temps
40 difficile ont pu rentrer difficile et
déplacement à une période donnée
et oui j'ai encore la photo fait de la
sieste ensemble la
la sieste
masque est terrible c'est que là je peux
vraiment la faire entre 14 et 17h après
j'arrive plus et je dors beaucoup moins
bien la nuit si j'envoie pas la sieste
je leur en ce moment comme je peux pas
envoyer de sieste avec le match je dors
moins à la nuit
tu dis si tu fais la tête j'arrive pas à
dormir la nuit moi c'est l'inverse tu es
trop fatigué pour ton dormir
mais oui mais toi aussi moi je fais
n'importe quoi
ah bah ça c'est l'énergie terrestre en
voie de la tienne on la récupère
ça peut être une sieste à 10h du matin
elle t'envoie tout le temps
pas souvent après 18h alors c'est
dangereux au pire c'est quand tu
t'endors vers trop tôt genre 22h 23h il
y a 1h du mat'
je fais une sieste la sieste avant
dur
tu peux descendre au salon avec Nikita
Ouais ouais j'ai pas bon je peux aussi
travailler comme le vais travailler
ça fait longtemps là ça fait très
longtemps j'ai très envie de
j'ai revu ta vidéo de bac et
du coup
un Maxime ambulant
l'adresse
je peux stream maintenant mais c'est
peut-être trop tard ah bah il peut
passer
alors du coup et sinon on fait on fait
la vidéo juste après le stream on fait
la vidéo après
est-ce qu'on fait les cadeaux après tu
allais faire maintenant non pas les
faire maintenant on va le faire chez toi
juste après on fera le résumé après
ouais
c'est plus c'est mieux non on va rester
station la peinture à s'arrêter plus
embêtant si la partie finissait à 20h
mais elle va elle va finir
à temps du coup il faut que je fasse le
truc pour qu'on puisse avoir Maxime
mais c'est vrai que là on a plus
grand-chose à dire quoi c'est terrible
cette partie
tomber il va gagner
mais il réfléchit au bon moment il a
raison ça peut être dangereux que pour
les noirs
de toute façon quand il y a Maxime on
est bien
en fait c'est plus complexe d'avoir la
la cam pour max mais bon j'ai envie de
dire c'est pas forcément le plus
important maki la caméra il va pas voir
tout ça
on verra peut-être pas forcément
Maxime en Visual 1
alors attends
normalement j'ai envoyé le lien
on va le récup
en fait on va on va mettre Maxime à la
place du truc
qu'on peut le mettre ici
on a pas les écouteurs donc vous pas
l'entendre
vas-y
c'est complexe pour moi
Salut Maxime est-ce que tu nous entends
moi je t'entends ok nickel pas qui
t'entends
super Salut max
aujourd'hui
il y avait des idées pour les blancs ça
c'est clair mais est-ce que tu penses
qu'il a loupé l'idée c'est 4 ou
qu'est-ce qu'il a loupé au moment
critique
passe un peu bizarre parce que
on va remettre la position
alors je sais pas ce que c'est vrai que
c'est 4 après peut-être c'est 4
je sais pas peut-être qu'il voulait pas
jouer laisser un truc genre fou et 6 x 4
c'est 6 je sais pas exactement en fait
il y avait sur moi c'est ce qu'on était
pas très bon bah c'est ce que c'est ce
que j'ai dit à maman mais c'est vrai que
c'est 5 pouces et 7 cavaliers des deux
ça fait mal quand même
ouais parce qu'après la demain 8h. C'est
exactement en fait c'est ça
ok ouais ça peut être du coup si on est
tous les dessus et après ça peut être
qu'il est plus ou moins louper l'idée la
force de l'idée C4 en fait
il est peut-être si c'est 4 C5 je sais
pas si
[Musique]
tu vois après oui
on est d'accord que le foot des 6 il est
mauvais mais après
c'est quoi tu as mais tu as x 4 pouces
et 6 et puis même
ça
on
sait pas en fait
c'est pas moi mais toi tu peux le dire
oui mais ça il va dire même avant avec
l'espagnol et tout quoi
donc par contre en vrai la finale là où
on est alors déjà un coup je sais pas
lequel toujours aller au 8
mois c'est ce que je pense je pense que
c'est un peu mieux pour les blancs parce
que
[Musique]
est-ce que des 6h oui mais dans notre
côté
on peut pas jouer ok 10 ans
je sais pas je maintenant centre tf5 et
ses 4 / 7 comme il y avait ces quatre
peut-être
17 mai mais il y avait des petites idées
il y a des tapas de C6 aussi à certains
moments je crois que tu es 17 par
exemple 5 pouces et 5 pour ça qu'il y a
pas du caramel
ok pas de chance avec
ok prends un cavalier des 5 c'est ça
que ça donne pas envie ça donne pas du
tout mais du coup
il est assez passif
[Musique]
ok mais je te dis que tu es un peu mieux
pour les blancs
mais
aujourd'hui
si tu veux
je suis partie 5 cavaliers
c44 mais je vais juste où je mange pas
et
ben on verra mais bon il y a pas mal de
après cavalier 8 il y a pas mal de
possibilités j'ai l'impression surtout
beaucoup trop faim là
je crois que c'est ça
ça fait toujours plaisir non mais en
fait j'ai l'impression que
c'est surtout que j'ai l'impression
parce que il va vers la nul plus que
j'ai pas s'il a vraiment envie de
pousser quoi en fait en vrai
alors ça c'est une autre question
sachant que c'est
en fait c'est
parce que
pendant 10 minutes un quart d'heure
ça montre que c'est pas si simple hein
ça c'est c'est clair c'est pas mon passé
simple c'est peut-être pas mal je sais
pas on nous dit que c'est le meilleur
coup de c'est c'est c'est logique
la Voie Lactée
[Musique]
j'étais à l'expo mais j'ai pas été dans
la salle de jeux sympas l'expo
d'ailleurs c'est sympa
mais mais je vais y retourner parce que
tu es content de ton travail auprès de
Magnus pour pour ce match
mais c'est les Russes pense que je suis
dans l'équipe à Magnus ça c'est
magnifique
ça se voit dans les coups
on m'a vu avec les Botta j'en ai fait
hier
après 7 turbo sur la Petrov
oui Manu ça réfléchis une heure de trop
je lui en veux beaucoup quand même
pour le cavalier 8-16 qu'est-ce que
c'était long ça c'est bien ça nous a
permis de faire un petit instant
plein de pub le petit instant alpha et
plein de trucs
mais il y en a pas
tu veux pas que ça dans le chat Maxime
Ouais mais j'assume
écoute je crois qu'on l'a tous
[Musique]
de qualité par contre en plus c'est mon
ancien ordi avec lequel je suis le
nouveau j'ai pas de caméra intégrée donc
tu as au sur mon nouvel ordi peut-être
que je n'ai pas ça en favoris que j'ai
encore plus qualitatif
en tout cas c'est la peur de tout les
streamer ce truc-là les historiques de
navigation les machins de pas tomber sur
une page et tu sais
mais de rien c'est vrai que
tu peux même
sans faire exprès
non c'était pas ça aurait pu être grave
en fait c'était que c'était pas grave en
fait mais ça aurait pu être
une information ou n'importe quoi
que tu regardes et tout
et
en fait
c'est bizarre
barbelé
ouais ça ça dépend ça dépend est-ce que
ça défensif là maintenant ça c'est bien
joué
alors
mets
7 caillou 6 et puis sur D8
ouais
après c'est toujours un petit peu chiant
genre est-ce qu'on a pas des quais f56
calice et 4
attends
ces quatre pour taper le foot APE 5
taper taper un peu partout c'est ça
après j'ai tellement du mal à croire
qu'on puisse gagner ça avec les Blancs
enfin contre Manu ça je suis aussi dans
le même dans la même optique que bah qui
met son doigt jouer avec les Blancs tu
dois jouer en fait si si tu lui envoie
le message que tu joues pas cette
position
mais tu es pas bien je lui donne un
avantage
et là et en plus ça
mais surtout
attends
je vais partager notre écran en fait je
vais je vais faire vas-y je vais faire
ça je suis non non non mais je vais
faire ça comme ça et en fait je vais
réussir je vais rajouter je sais pas
comment je vais faire je suis en train
de réfléchir
et après on verra
tu vois c'est très facile mais vraiment
les barbelés
C4 essence
ça fait pas envie c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas dit que ça fasse nul en fait
partie
ça fait plusieurs fois qu'on lui donne
l'espoir
en plus j'aime bien ensuite
c'est vrai c'est qu'une fois 5 un des
plans des noirs pour se libérer c'est à
5 et 6
mai
G4 prophylactique empêche hashtag
après tu peux continuer après c'est avec
genre des F3 H4 H5 qui est
désagréable
tu dis désolé j'étais en plein j'étais
en plein réglages pour t'ajouter
t'inquiète et aussi et c'est pour D8
donc là tu joues G4
il a jamais fait 6 ans qu'elle prend un
fils et après tu peux jouer des H4 H5
tu me ramènera ton roi petit à petit et
évidemment c'est encore nul mais
objectivement mets en doute pas que
tu as un mois en et pot aussi va la
jouer peut-être que Magnus là j'aurais
même que d'autres avec les Blancs
n'importe mais en tout cas je n'ai pas
eu raison de pas la joie et après on
défense de finale un peu inférieure
Magnus c'est pas forcément le plus fort
non plus
Ouais après c'est sûr c'est final c'est
ici que je pense que si que c'est un jeu
de manœuvre à un jeu de
position quand même
donc en vrai si je pense qu'il va tenir
assez facilement
30 minutes pas très important pour
l'instant il a que ça à faire
mets une impression de plus et ça
devient très chiant c'est la première
fois qu'il est vraiment sous pression au
noir Magnus dans le match et ça veut
dire que le choix de l'espagnol il est
peut-être pas si mauvais côté côté n'est
pas
amène de toute façon en fait moi ce que
je pense c'est que dans un match c'est
bien c'est
l'intérêt c'est pas taper sur
l'adversaire
plusieurs fois sur le sur le point
faible parce que surtout sur un match de
championnat du monde où les mecs sont
séparés en fait cette première partie
pour moi et cerveau finir des infos
très très dur de faire la différence
avec les Blancs
quand tu connais pas Oberthür adverse
par exemple première partie contre
Magnus s'est
envolé le mec a préparé ça pendant 6
mois et
ils s'étaient préparés et
en plus ensuite
mais ce que je veux dire c'est comment
la première partie révise révise la Wii
me révise la marche en
avant la première partie donc va voir
les options un peu plus un peu les
produits
côté n'est pas avec soi en première
partie en marche parce que
parce qu'il pouvait pas être sûr que ce
serait Marshall donc c'est pour ça qu'il
lui a donné une belle position qu'il a
pas forcément bien joué mais en réalité
Puteaux marcher sa prépa dans la
première en soit
qui sont et donc je pense que c'est
aussi la stratégie alors là où on est
une anti Marshall c'est que
normalement ma nièce la réviser alors là
il a changé c'est un peu bizarre je sais
pas trop pourquoi peut-être c'est
quelque chose qui est pas trop aussi il
a joué dans la troisième peut-être qu'il
avait prévu comme ça mais c'est très
bizarre parce que tu l'auras mieux connu
en fait la réaction de Magnus m'a
beaucoup étonné
quelque part en fait ce qu'il a fait
parce que je pense que ce
n'est pas le cas très très bien même si
bon au bout d'un moment dans le match à
force de les réviser réviser en tout cas
toujours réveillé et maintenant qu'il a
l'info Petrov
pas beaucoup plus poussé à gauche à
droite
ça c'est j'aime bien et donc maintenant
c'est clair que pour moi par exemple sur
4 mais il doit surtout pas partir sur
ces quatre cavaliers
contrairement à ce qu'il avait fait dans
son match contre Caruana je pense que ça
c'était une erreur
dans mon esprit
à ce niveau de préparation en fait en
match de championnat du monde
c'est clair il faut taper de face à des
endroits assez profond ça c'est pour
mettre en danger l'adversaire tu peux
pas y aller superficiellement
[Musique]
appelle touché le cœur de la préparation
adverse c'est ça tu veux vraiment tapé
pas là où il peut y avoir des problèmes
et d'ailleurs si tu commences en gagner
une tu prends gagné deux tu prends gagné
3 en fait avec sa stratégie la oui c'est
ça après évidemment
essayer de taper le cœur de la
préparation de faire ça peut alors moi
maintenant parce que les autres sont
tellement fort en fait tu peux à la fois
taper le cœur de la préparation et aussi
ne courir aucun respect et blanc mais il
n'est pas que c'était le problème de
cette
c'est que ça pouvait donner ce qui s'est
passé dans le match cramique en vichy en
il sait faire la foi surprendre par le
choix de la maison mais en plus il s'est
fait
il a tapé
il a tapé dans le cœur de la préparation
mais en étant pas à se préparer
se prendre en compte c'est bon quand tu
capte partir et blanc sur un match
c'est une question de bac tu peux lui
donner un petit morceau si tu veux
un petit peu mais même un petit peu de
mortadelle ou quoi ça se passe
dans notre salle
il y a
un match de championnat
et tu connais l'amour de Baki pour pour
les animaux et notamment pour les chiens
qui aime beaucoup les chiens c'est vrai
que il en parle pas souvent mais mais
maintenant moi je suis complètement
cerné ma sœur aussi un chien c'est plus
difficile
il y en aura pas tout de suite
mais je commence à bien cerner ou que
j'aille je peux être accueilli par
Arnaud à me
déguiser t'inquiète pas ça va venir
petit à petit après tu vas t'habituer tu
non mais en vrai ça va maintenant c'est
quand j'étais jeune
[Musique]
la turbine hydraulique qui a du sens
après
est-ce que sûr qu'il y a 5 minutes ne va
vraiment pas jouer ton bébé donc ça
ok
mais
avec la tour la tour B2 c'est trop ça
donne trop d'activités même pas tomber
tomber trop mais je pense être
p33 mieux
c'est mieux
du coup ça on peut pas vraiment
pour empêcher puis
ces deux et
par exemple
5 et non ils ont pas grand chose à faire
en attendant
bah après j'ai qu'à toi c'est
possible
H4 H5 et puis toi aussi tu as 4 g 5 tu
peux jouer H4 et tu peux attendre que
ça c'est pas mal et toi aussi tu G5
parfois et tu attends
alors après là ça tient mais ça tient
assis dans déjà on voit bien l'idée de
venir vraiment taper sur la structure
j'ai 4 j'aime bien juste pour expliquer
lisez ce qu'est ce qui est Maxime c'est
qui n'ont les noirs vont faire à chemin
que même puis j'ai ici c'est chasser le
cavalier là ça va pas être assez
et donc j'ai 4 ça permet d'empêcher H5
et j'ai 6 tu pourras jamais parce que à
Calais.
c'est vraiment très logique
après c'est sûr que Manu cela ça sert le
coup
est-ce que c'est sûr que Paul a un peu
moins sûr mais je pense que
je comprends que tu aies une idée tu
trouves G4 c'est pas un souci c'est
qu'un plastique A5 V6 mangeur de
position entre ça et le roi je crois H7
G6 bon mais là qui est pas possible
c'est de plomb vraiment classique c'est
classique
tu dois l'avoir
après ça doit être plus difficile en jeu
et c'est parti comme ça haute pression
mais toi tu en avais joué une il y a pas
si longtemps au barreau grand Suisse au
candidat est-ce que tu sens que c'est
les couilles s'ils sont plus durs à
venir ou pas
ça dépend après ça dépend la situation
de moi je considère que les couilles
sont plus dures à venir quand en
difficulté après
[Musique]
si tu te retrouves en difficulté sur les
chéquiers et que tu ajoutes ça avec le
stress du résultat là oui ça peut se
cumuler mais sinon c'était une partie
facile important ça va tu cliques quoi
il avait sorti une grosse partie aux
candidats dans cette partie en jeu il
avait bien serré quoi
en fait c'est un moment il avait un peu
trop serré
mais ensuite j'avais réussi à trouver
les deux trois beaucoup justement
pour bien remettre ses pièces et
comprendre que j'aurais pas que j'aurais
pas ma chance
il a une grosse partie ce jour-là et
c'est vrai qu'il a l'impression d'avoir
progresser en maturité là tu n'es pas
un peu plus tard qu'il y a 2 ans
c'est pas lancer une partie 1 contre 1 2
secondes
il était cool il est un petit peu
coutumier de ce genre de
toi
et puis pour partie 2 partie 3 partie
aussi ça pouvait ne pas se limiter à une
seule
oui je m'appelle pas
en fait
Ouais mais tu as changé beaucoup de
choses tu sombre jamais vraiment non
plus quoi
ça fait longtemps
quand même
parce que c'était le premier tournoi
poste Ovide
comme ça ça a joué et puis c'est vrai
que ça m'allait toujours bien réussi
mais un tournoi de 13 ronde quand ça se
passe bien généralement ok on reste
focus et puis
et puis je tape sur les mecs qui sont
moins bien mais quand ça se passe mal
après c'est tout sur toi et c'est bon là
ta prochaine échéance comme on parle de
ça c'est les c'est les Grands Prix fille
tu as tu as tu as plus de tournoi entre
alors normalement j'ai le temps que tu
as du monde rapide et
tout ça
et je m'occupe de ça
mais c'est quand même un objectif aussi
parce que finalement de champion du
monde de
moins de spectateurs vraiment dans une
carrière c'est pas
vraiment en fait
tu as quasiment tout le monde qui le
joue actuellement c'est c'est plus comme
à une certaine époque où ces
championnats du monde il manque beaucoup
de monde là maintenant tu vas voir Manu
je vais sûrement avoir Hikaru tu vas
voir Alireza j'imagine je suis pas sûr à
100 %
il vient pas
aussi à cause de
quoi
ah non c'est clair
non du coup
[Musique]
après évidemment l'objectif principal ça
reste pour la qualif
de rien en fait quand il arrive
même si on va dire que dans 3,4 ans et
plus en mesure
d'essayer d'être champion du monde même
si évidemment je vais je vais me battre
pour ça mais bon admettons dans 34 ans
pas plus en capacité de physique de
faire ça
pendant 5 jours et joint
rapide c'est ça ça me semble
complètement possible quand il arrive
dans 34 ans ça sera le faire pendant 10
ans encore j'imagine voilà bien sûr
donc
après j'ai jamais réussi j'étais proche
très proche une fois
mais je crois que j'ai fait qu'un seul
podium a complètement sia
j'ai fait une 4e place en 2019 avec le
moral dans les chaussettes tu me
rappellerai sur la cité si tu avais tu
avais pu jouer à 100 % tu répètes gagné
si tu savais que tu étais chaud
Ouais mais j'ai trop mal démarré c'est
pas enfin moment j'ai fini par me
motiver mais je sais pas du tout
à la déception c'est grand prix c'est
normal donc en tout cas oui je vais tout
donner dans les Grands Prix
après je serai pas tout seul emmener
Cedeo case j'ai déjà raté pas mal
d'occas en vrai là faut pas faut pas le
rater j'aimerais tellement que que tu
gagnes honnêtement là ce serait
tellement cool de te voir te calife au
candidat est tellement mérité aussi
après
[Musique]
une fois j'envoie
pas très loin
mais au final c'est pas un truc qui
s'est joué en demi-finale sur 1 ans donc
cet été plus loin plus loin à la Coupe
du monde dans le sens tu as perdu plutôt
d'un autre côté c'était un peu la
demi-finale avant l'heure le matin tu
m'as appris Faloci bat les les joueurs à
venir mais oui oui mais je veux dire
c'est pas pareil
tu étais pas loin non plus vrai ça joue
tu as quoi
et puis aussi un peu sur Caruana qui
trouve tous les coups
par contre
j'étais vraiment impressionné par la
partie j'étais même pas que j'ai
pour toi
je peux pas faire mieux en fait
est-ce que tu peux faire de plus
si j'aurais pu mieux jouer cette partie
en bas mais j'aurais pu lui poser plus
de problème mais je pense que
vu comment il jouait n'aurait pas changé
le résultat mais malgré tout j'avais des
opportunités de faire
plus mal dans le sens poser plus de
problème
il a vraiment été très impressionnant
aussi
vraiment été dans Caruana il a il a il a
vraiment bien joué du coup tu as moins
17 moins de déception je sais pas toi
pas en tant que spectateur en tout cas
tu as moins de déception quand tu as
l'impression d'être tombé sur un gars
qui
déception quand j'ai quand j'ai quand
j'ai trop
[Musique]
nul au lieu de juste jouer je vais te
laisser patauger quoi essaie de finale
de pions du coup tu penses que tu aurais
pu
c'était trouvable ou pas ce que c'est
que les turbines montrer
je pense que de loin c'est pas trouvable
en fin de mon côté je pense pas que
j'aurai trouvé parce que je voyais
vraiment pas en fait de chance mais
juste en mettant le rang des 4
allez les trois coups naturel avec A3
C4D 4 et laisser
laisser un monsieur Shirov se rendre
compte petit à petit
c'est pas aussi sans qu'il le pensait
donc le laisser calculer
et du coup ça ça maintient lui aussi que
c'est pas si facile les du coup je vais
peut-être trouver des quoi partir de ce
que tu veux dire c'est trouver un peu
mécaniquement avancer la partie et
je pense que c'est très très dur de
trouver d'autres
personnes
mais bon c'est une pause c'est la faute
c'est juste de pas avoir joli coup
naturel et d'avoir fait ça nul comme ça
après après ça ça arrive aussi on va
dire que tu as une petite déception par
rapport à ça
ça
aurait pu bien tourner aussi
même si je me qualifie pas
mal
quand même
après non il a fait
donc par contre il y en a joué donc
il a fait 6
ans que j'ai 6
ans
se dit qu'il va blindé comme ça et que
ta mère
peut-être aussi alors peut-être que sur
mais ça me semble bizarre mais peut-être
que sur H5 n'est pas voulez j'ai 400 ans
j'ai 4 c'est peut-être ça
ça me semble bizarre c'est pas comme ça
que je jouerai ah non
c'est trop en fait après si ça tourne
bien
passé à chemin mais il y a trop de sport
ça passerait
le truc c'est qu'il y a pas assez de
faiblesse à côté oui après il jouait
mais bon moment ils veulent jouer à
considérer qu'après ces quatre
6 ans 7 ans 8 ans aussi
ça fait quelques barbelés c'est sûr ça
travaille côté Baki
mais qui nous dit qu'il y a rien
ah bah là oui c'est des chefs
c'est un coup c'est pas logique ça
protège 4
mais là encore une fois alors tu es sans
doute pas mieux avec ses blancs mais si
tu es mieux
c'est avec des coups précis c'est pas
Jean-Michel à peu près
ça je sais que ça peut être aussi une de
mes faiblesses juste un peu trop à peu
près dans des positions vraiment la
précision Mallet
et ça c'est sa demande en état de forme
que peut-être en fait mais Paul n'a pas
et non plus d'ailleurs match en
fait entre des joueurs aussi fort pour
faire une différence
au niveau
pas niveau numéro mondial c'est pas cool
jouer les coups à 28
52901 pendant longtemps aime bien le
dire
oui après non après tu peux en trouver
deux ou trois qui crée une différence
énorme pas par exemple il y avait
des cas où tu es différent ça c'est
après c'est facile à jouer donc du coup
il se retrouve sous pression ou quoi en
fait
c'est comme ça
parce que
ils ont joué
lance si tu joues contre l'ordi et
l'ordi et Jul tout les meilleurs coups
mets en mode c'est parti d'hab a pas
compte du coup
mais en fait l'ordi il joue les cours
alors là c'est que tu as 2852 x 2907 x
3002 x 1000 x 3004
c'est très dur à visualiser mais en tout
cas c'est les cookies te force en tant
qu'humain à trouver des pas facile
fais vite fais vite fais jouer quoi
entre guillemets voilà il fait jouer et
si tu peux jouer à 2006-2007
parce que derrière tu vas te reprendre
des coups A3300
pas
pas de marge d'erreur et qu'il a sorti
tous les cartons là oh là là oh que oui
attentat sorti il a sorti à il a sorti
un Maxime Vachier Lagrave joueur
d'échecs il faut parfois faire un petit
sacrifice pour prendre l'avantage
c'est sorti ça parle 13h tous les la
sortie des finales échecs pour les
enfants
cool avec qui
je crois qu'il y a un coup de fil de
Nathan il va partir
différents coups de fil de Nath il va
partir ça va te calmer
c'est ça
là du coup il est il est bien il a
récupéré toutes les énergies terrestre
oui j'ai reçu j'ai reçu
il est content là-bas qui est très
heureux
Ah très très heureux bâti tu peux la
montrer tu l'as monte sur 7 km du coup
j'ai mis Maxime sur ta cam
tu te mettes là
table avec moi méchant
et oui
ah la la
mais ça peut durer encore longtemps bah
qui vient cette partie
oui
c'est possible
mais je le serai tout seul pour voir les
la dernière les dernières 2 heures de
jeu pour finir à 22h à Paris
est-ce que ça peut finir à 22h je pense
pas non ça peut finir à 20h30 non après
en vrai ça peut finir
ça y a des petits cas où ça finit dans
pas dans 10 minutes mais tu as 25
minutes
au quarantième ouais genre cette fois ce
qui paraît encore une
et si tu pouvais jouer
le micro
Harold pour ensuite ramener penser de
Seyssins
j'entendais pas on est on est on est
dans un Big Mac
magnifique
transférer le roi en ces deux encore
ouais c'est ça on en a parlé d'ailleurs
vous en avez parlé ok c'est encore un
peu pour cette fois mais là dans la
partie
j'ai 4 h 4 donc du coup c'est jouer mais
maintenant faut et fille
une fois c'est peut-être que je sois pas
quelque chose
barbelé
ressemblant
après là il commence à y avoir vraiment
passé
il a fait
rapidement et ben Taylor
c'est terrible c'est 40 cm alors
40e
de ça va aller jusqu'au 40e et ça va ça
va gros
bon bah
ça mérite le minimum
c'est pas assez il est pas bien
moins qui est une vraie boule est là
il va lui faire cayde-6
ok difficile
acquis des 6 jours
je pense que là maintenant alors après
c'est peut-être possible de pas
complètement zappé le joint cavalier à 5
mais ça peut aussi
masala risquerait du coup
non mais ça va être pris
moi je suis presque prêt pour le pour le
résumé en fait mais tu veux qu'on fasse
tu veux qu'on fasse pas les roues avant
quand même quand même
on fait un peu les roues ont fait quoi
en fait une heure un peu de roue un peu
de Paris on se on se croirait pas 1er
décembre
à Cannes fait super beau il fait super
beau
c'est bon ça c'est ouvert
croyable
ouais on est bien sauf sur cette partie
le chat qui se tient
plus parler
tu as tu rentres sur éclairer qui va se
prendre une pub aussi
mais oui magnifique
c'est magnifique ça
je suis venu pour rien
Ludwig est très heureux
pour cette partie
le modérateur sur
tf1
Alexis payerai
une victoire que ça te bloque le
compteur je ne reviendrai sûrement pas
pour la prochaine
c'est le Tour de France
et puis
un petit peu de vent
[Musique]
c'est terrible est-ce que tu as payé le
profit des sont tous les deux à table
quand même aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'il
y a eu plus d'action visuel et puis mais
dommage la les plus belles fini
arrêter de parler de nouveau
complexe à Aix et complexe
il se donne à fond et les joueurs ils
sont tout ce qu'ils peuvent donc c'est
ça en tout cas il a pas envie de prendre
des si
il y a un peu de cinéma peut-être c'est
vrai que avant de faire ça peut
m'arriver de
vraiment
se voir quand si j'ai plein de
possibilités car genre
je m'ennuie un peu fait le spécialiste à
Nice pour faire ça pour prétendre qu'il
avait l'avantage avec son cul 0,12
il est très heureux et il est très
heureux
c'est ça le plus important
là c'est pas plus 0,12 lames
oh que oui
est-ce que tu fais des traductions libre
des conférences de presse non pas du
tout pas du tout j'essaye
de me paraît plus vite possible et
aussi est-ce que tu as que si tu les as
regardé les conférences de presse que tu
comprends les questions
je peux les comprendre facilement
mais bon je laisse ça aux autres
je ne mange pas de ce pain-là
[Musique]
Ouais ou alors dans 4 ou en vrai ça peut
faire une répète dans 4 exactement une
autre possibilité de façon c'est 100 %
sûr que ça va faire nul
en passant c'est pas le plus important
de la journée c'est qui va gagner la
roue le plus important ouais
je sais pas encore parce qu'ils nous ont
mis un peu dans le dur
c'est obligatoire c'est toi Maxime
ah bah ouais mais c'est vraiment toi est
vraiment moi je suis vraiment joueur
d'échecs en fait
aïe aïe aïe
ils sont tous partis là ils sont tous
partis bah il a encore du temps on est
Pau et sûrement
sachant que c'est un peu dommage tu
aimes que les parties traîne un peu en
longueur quand c'est vraiment nul nul
quoi
c'est pas si cette règle attendre le 40e
Ouais mais on remarque c'est pas dit qui
propose si c'était ça change rien en
fait
en plus tu me l'as pas fou b64 échec
donc tu auras
droit à
toi non
et je vois bien le tour à cette heure-ci
c'est Magnus qui revient en premier il
est parti chercher dépôt dans sa loge
mais pourquoi ça fait 3 partie 2 partie
comment c'est comment ça se passe pas
être font 3 de 3 de
encore une idée pour
des spectateurs une faute des suiveurs
pour être bien sûr qu'il y a de l'action
en fait on aura peut-être peut-être une
défaite par forfait dans des joueurs
j'étais vraiment pas
en fait plus drôle non
mais moi je
[Musique]
vais à la salle de jeux en premier
mais ça c'est fou il arrive il est
arrivé 15 minutes avant aussi
une fois moi ça me semble complètement
fou d'arriver 15 minutes avant
la Tabaski qui arrive un quart d'heure
avant
j'ai jamais vu dans un tournoi
quelqu'un arrive un quart d'heure avant
en fait
jamais
je dis par exemple candidat jamais
[Musique]
jamais au grand Suisse en tout cas c'est
pas moi qui arrive dans un quart d'heure
avant qu'elle 5 10 minutes avant poser
mais c'est en fait c'est ça
10 minutes c'est bien
voir le match peut-être
tu sais pas peut-être
mais surtout que c'est c'est pas
tellement son genre je crois que
candidat il arrive de 3 minutes avant
max
après ce qu'il y a de l'eau contrôle de
sécurité ou quoi mais j'imagine que non
toute façon ça a été très pas une
arrivée un quart d'heure en avance tu
peux avoir un long contrôle de sécurité
même un contrôle qui dure 2 minutes par
joueur mais déjà ce sera jamais plus et
de joueurs seulement
passe ton contrôle quoi
non non c'est vrai que c'est c'est vrai
que par contre ça j'avais
passer le point complexe en fait
c'est pour pour les commentaires c'est
vrai que et même pour le pour les
spectateurs plus gros bah oui c'est bon
ça
mais évidemment ça c'est encore un autre
optimal
voilà c'est
un peu comme hier aujourd'hui
hier c'était vraiment
très longtemps
[Musique]
Bah vas-y si tu veux t'inquiète pas avec
je vais je vais m'absenter
30 secondes j'arrive
il y a pas de
toute façon j'ai envie de dire moi aussi
je me barre
qu'est-ce que c'est les commentaires
très intéressant tout le monde par quoi
à l'autre qui restait finalement
oh que oui il doit nous faire la
miniature pour cette partie il a son
imagination pour les miniatures il faut
dire nous on nous a fait des miniatures
comme c'est ouverture
ouverture ça progresse
moi ça progresse doucement je crois
ça progresse doucement en ouverture
Ludwig
et c'est durant les échecs quand même
et je suis de retour c'est vraiment 30
secondes là c'était lui
il a déjà préparé il fait comme moi en
fait pour la partie là pour le pour le
recap déjà fait quoi
en fait
ah bah oui
on s'est parlé avant on avait dit
prépare à
oui je pense que
[Musique]
14h14 c'est une victoire chacun si
jamais
mais tu crois toi 14000 Maxime
bien sûr que j'ai toujours cru en fait
ce serait beau carrément pas ce serait
beau
c'est forcément une possibilité dans ses
matchs là clairement Bah surtout depuis
que
la prise de risque beaucoup plus solide
au candidat et il a il a pas fait les
différences entre les jours en forme
quoi que la science dit que ma nuit ce
n'est pas forcément très en forme bon ça
reste c'est la porte principale de ma
nièce d'ailleurs même pas ensemble
il reste très fort
ce serait bon allez 14000 tu viendrais
pour l'été partage baquis à 14000 aller
mais c'est quand j'aime pas quand c'est
le 15 non
tu es déjà déjà le 15
repas tu es déjà le web à qui
[Musique]
non tu me diras il y a une partie
décisive à la 100e premier match
après c'était une finale complètement
égal à la base
voir vie c'est un peu mieux d'ailleurs
il avait été un peu trop début de
l'autre côté des chances
c'est pas terminé nul
match aussi aurait été
différent
et peut-être plus proche des 12 nul
à quand la prépa des jours à ce
niveau-là déjà et puis
bah oui ça fait 6 mois qui pense qu'à ça
donc
c'est dur de se dire par exemple un coup
vraiment à côté de Tours à 5 peut-être
petite proposition de répétition 8 il
propose la nuit il invite tous racistes
et ça peut être jouée
magnifique Magnus à très très bientôt je
t'aime pas
malin à très marrant
ça peut être signé dans 3 minutes
hier il aurait fait cavalier 8 6
rapidement et on aurait fait le tour à 6
tempo mais c'est vraiment que parce que
hier il lui a joué c'est terrible
mais
[Musique]
c'est normal
j'imagine s'il a pas joué tour c'est
il essaie de ramener son roi du
en vrai à Tours à 8 m pour oui
évidemment c'est pas déjà
assis
30 avenue du roi des trois il veut jouer
la tour des deux ou trois tiroirs C4
qu'est-ce qui se passe sur des trois on
va faire travailler le chat un peu
j'ai mis la position
noir
ça perd pas en plus ça perd pas
complètement
maintenant
non mais je pensais que ça te faire des
sauvages il y a 3,5 ans
[Musique]
maintenant
trouve le meilleur coup
Renault il y a plus de meilleur quoi en
fait quand même
meilleur la meilleure chance
c'est trop dur là c'est trop dur roi de
7 on voit roi des cèpes et la le
sauvetage miraculeux
est-ce que ça va trouver dans le
chat, c'est miraculeux
je montre
C4 échecs
je comprends car elle épaissit Séchet
croise et 6 et puis on prend des destins
qu' est-ce qu' est-ce que je te prends à
8sa
d4action prends pas vraiment
encore plus fort
on imagine que ça gagne quelque part
elle avait prendre des cinq
intermédiaire et celle à qui on a une
cavalerie incroyable on va repartir sur
le direct
avec Manu ça y en a marre
ah bah c'est mérité
il ne fallait pas d'aller jouer
il va faire quoi il a fait roi des trois
et il va laisser la tour s'infiltrer où
bac ES désespéré aussi
je
vais peut-être vous laisser désespéré
tout ça là si ça continue trop longtemps
et qui va qui s'est barré
Amira d'être en retard ces quatre il
peut tomber
il prépare les cadeaux il fait il fait
plein de choses là-bas qui
et 3 ans après ça ça joue encore
donc est-ce que Magnus un peu c'est pas
un peu désactiver comme ça
pas du tout il a fait tourner de à mon
avis
sur des 17 ans
j'ai déjà mettre le titre du
du raid
je mets quelques cadeaux et partie
pédagogique avec Baki en fait 2 3
[Musique]
mais en fait
45 ans
ça peut proposer mais là je pense que ça
va faire drôle
Karim tu vas partir pédagogique et
cadeau avec Étienne Bacrot
ouais donc en résumé c'est vrai que
cette pression mais ce n'est pas un tout
petit peu mais pas assez aujourd'hui il
a assez
avec la position
les les possibilités là-bas c'est pas
assez c'est ouvert il avait des lignes
je critique quoi est ce genre de
position contre justement contre un ordi
Samsung parce que
il va poser des problèmes de A à Z
le gars des partis comme celle d'hier
sur la Petrov en vrai ce serait possible
d'annuler contre un ordi
mais
à partir du début de la finale allez bon
courage c'est bien c'est facile là
la la base après ces quatre ça va très
très bien tourné pour lui non c'est
terrible c'est terrible en fait une
victoire pour vraiment débloquer les
parties quoi ça débloque ça c'est sûr
ça débloque dans le sens où à la 6e
c'est Manu ce qui me dejo serai de
nouveau une victoire pour Magnus entre
guillemets toutes les parties après
elles ont un lien storytelling tout le
temps en fait
par contre il y a un truc qui me plaît
c'est que leur a été rajouté on a passé
le 40e est-ce que
mais pas non pas pour prendre bien son
temps pour être bien sûr
possible un petit tour et tu te lèves
tu te lèves
après 15 minutes de réflexion ensuite
quoi qu'il arrive tu reste 20 minutes
dans ta loge
ben oui mais tu peux faire ça enfin je
sens qu'il part pour ça il veut il veut
lui faire payer le truc d'hier en fait
ouais très clairement donc la part en la
tu peux arriver
moi ça me fait
vas-y voilà
au bout de ton côté c'est du masochisme
non je mange et
toi tu peux partir pour nous c'est
bon on essaie de trouver une idée
et encore une fois c'est une idée mais
est-ce qu'on peut pas jouer de tour B2
décès Roy 17 pour B8 et éventuellement.
c'est l'idée qui sans micro mais tu me
montres GDC prendre et puis prendre j'ai
ça te prendra fils
je pense que même ça ça doit être nul
mais bon ça ça peut cliquer
[Musique]
et du coup sûr tomber 2
maintenant sur toi 8 jours à d'être AC4
et tendre encore
mais bon
non mais là à mon avis je pars toujours
du principe dans tous les cas si tu
commences à avoir forcé ce genre de truc
tu te mets plus dans le problème
qu'autre chose en fait donc tu as aucun
intérêt à le faire
non bien sûr mais après en vrai nom de
ton bébé peut être une idée
ça peut être une vraie évidemment
j'apparais que généralement avec les
Blancs fait la cam tu as plus intérêt à
faire tourner autour des deux nuls que
bien sûr parce que sinon tu vas tenter
tes
histoire d'être bien sûr tu vas passer
une demi-heure position
je suis assez d'accord avec toi là je
pense que s'il avait voulu faire nul il
aurait déjà c'est nul voilà et puis
au journée de repos demain ça change pas
grand-chose
pour lui en termes de
de forme physique qui sont prêt à rester
sur le site j'en peux plus
très bien ça me plaît beaucoup et sur ce
je pense que même que je vais y aller on
ne pas avoir à subir cette de merde de
réflexion ah non ah non
quand je dis ça à quoi mais la du coup
tu vas y aller aussi parce que ça va
faire dans quelques minutes Maxime dans
quelques secondes 2 secondes
Magnus rencontre pour ado
ah bah oui mais bon c'était sûr
c'était sûr en fait
ça va faire nul et il propose et propose
pas nul en ils vont sur la répète je
pense que tous les deux tous les deux ça
devrait sinon
Ah peut-être alors peut-être
ah oui mais faut mettre une petite pub
pour être sûr de ne pas rater la fin de
la partie
magnifique mais il repart en réflexion
ça ça me plaît beaucoup
moi il me va le faire la fête du cinéma
et oui pendant la pub magnifique
c'est signé
et c'est signé en main du coup merci
Maxime d'être venu avec nous dommage que
tu sois pas tombé sur la partie la plus
intéressante en tout cas sur le moment
de la partie le plus
c'est un peu bloqué mais
je repasserai sans doute ah bah quand tu
veux tu m'écris toute façon dès que tu
veux passer ce soir avant après pendant
tu me fais un petit message et puis et
puis on discute un peu de la partie
après la soirée qu'aujourd'hui c'était
pas ça fait beaucoup de promesses en
fait finalement
pas tenu des promesses non tenues des
promesses non tenues mais
c'est
aussi une forme active
après
il y a des partisans
tête de nombre de partie peut-être de te
contrôler de temps peut-être aussi
d'avoir un mix de cadencement tout cas
bon bah tu es parti alors là on a pas de
partir de 7h mais quand on en aura où il
se passe rien là ça va être terrible par
rapport au match de Caruana là on a un
peu de bol c'est que bah là encore
aujourd'hui c'est parti de 3h30
non plus super allons bon après ce qui
est un peu difficile c'est que c'est sûr
que les gens qui pouvait être IP par par
l'événement au début en fait tu vas plus
ça passe surtout quand on fait du grand
grand public c'est quoi
après
après-demain donc une journée de repos
il peut jouer des 4
sans la très très grosse partie la
partie charnière
2 jours
parce que ça va on va rester encore dans
le dans le moment où tu as le temps de
revenir derrière donc tu peux risquer
et puis
encore une fois
donc ça c'est pas négligeable
ouais
voilà bon ben sur ce la bascule sur ce
Maxime on va faire la bascule avec avec
bac qui qui va tout un tas de cadeaux et
on souhaite de passer un bon moment à
Dubaï et on te dis à bientôt et est-ce à
bientôt et à toi
alors attendez
qu'on revoit Baki qui aurait pas qui est
en train de bosser on va faire la
bascule
ah oui tu peux oui oui oui tu peux
continuer à bosser où on va en fait on
fait la bise on fait la bascule au moins
on en voit
on envoie les cadeaux j'avais tout
préparé pour donc attendez 30 secondes
attendez 30 secondes ici ça devrait
partir
ça devrait partir
merci d'avoir suivi et on vous dit à
après-demain pour